hearing this morning we have a number of
bills on the dock which are going to be
hearing
um as a note for the committee members
on our calendar I have put a tentative
calendar it's probably going to be more
than tentative at noon today where we
will not be meeting on next Monday
and the Thursday of course will be a
session
uh we're not going to be meeting this
Thursday either for a work session
that's we're going to push that off to
later on in the calendar so there's you
can guarantee this Thursday and next
Monday we will be working on Tuesday
Wednesday session on Thursday and we
will have an exact session all day on
Friday as well all these schedules will
include
exact sessions as well so there will be
a work session on one of those days for
some of our finance bills which are
policy bills as well
so that's just a quick note so what I'd
like to do is get into house bill 230
272 this is increasing Charter Public
School per pupil funding uh the prime
responsible is representative Mooney and
water uh recognize and welcome represent
money to our committee I'm also going to
ask people that are testifying today if
something's already been spoken to in
testimony about this please don't
replicate that it will just drag us on
and put our whole schedule
in Peril so please try to state to the
times that you've
requested and and not and and don't
repeat what somebody else if you have
testimony and writing we'd appreciate
that too that saves our clerk from
having to write all that down we can say
see attached paperwork
so thank you very much and Welcome to
our committee thank you much very much
Mr chairman and good morning to members
of the committee for the record my name
is representative Maureen Mooney I'm
from the town of Merrimack it's
Hillsborough County District number 12.
I'm the prime sponsor and here to
testify in support of House Bill 272 and
act relative to increasing chartered
Public School per pupil funding
Now by means of some background public
charter schools in New Hampshire are
funded using this formula
there is base adequacy amount per pupil
then you have what is called in statute
and additional Grant
edly that is what my bill addresses the
additional Grant
both the adequacy amount and the
additional Grant are subject to the
Consumer Price Index
in addition to those two there's also
applicable differentiated Aid that
applies specifically in a statute
another statute to specific
circumstances for example English as a
second language learning
so those three formulas
my bill refers only to the additional
Grant piece of the three
prong formula
House Bill 272 increases the statutory
additional Grant given to public charter
schools per pupil
placing the amount in the statute for
the additional Grant
as
5141 dollars
per the fiscal note the increase in
House Bill 272
amounts to
one thousand five hundred fourteen
dollars and twelve cents of an increase
per Charter School pupil in fiscal year
24.
what is the overall picture
the overall is that with this increase
the total per pupil for public charter
schools
based on the formula described above
or what I mentioned would be
approximately now nine thousand dollars
per public chartered school pupil
this is up
from the approximate
seven thousand four hundred dollars per
pupil
that public charter schools receive
currently
there are several reasons for increasing
the additional Grant
first of all the additional Grant has
not been increased since House Bill 517
in 2017.
so there's not been an increase
funding at nine thousand dollars per
pupil is still lower
than traditional Public Schools where
the most recent figure I've heard is an
average of nineteen thousand five
hundred dollars per pupil in traditional
public school districts
increased funding is needed with
increased enrollment
in public chartered schools as we've
seen
a recent article
by Ethan DeWitt
from November of 2022
has a headline of New Hampshire Charter
School enrollment increases 14 percent
for these reasons
and with this description which I hope
is clear as it is a tiny bit complicated
but I tried to articulate it as best I
could in terms of what the bill will do
I would ask for your support of the bill
if that'll conclude my testimony thank
you Mr chair thank you very much are
represent cordelli and thank you Mr
chairman uh thank you representative
Mooney for uh presenting the bill
um
it seems to me that there have been a
few
chartered public schools
that have failed over the past
X number of years and I'm just wondering
how the finances have played into those
failures given the testimony you just
gave about the public school traditional
public school funding versus Charter uh
uh not knowing specifically the schools
you're referring to not having those
details I would defer that to um one
that would testify after me
are there further questions of
Representative Mooney
did somebody have their hand up over
there
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee my name is Dawn Winterton I
live in Hooksett I am the chair of the
Board of Trustees of the Polaris public
charter schools one of the successes
that you should come and see we have a
we have room we're in the old St Patrick
School in the west side of Manchester we
are not in a high-end neighborhood
believe me we are not but we uh educate
120 kids from K through five
as you probably know Charter Schools
allow new students in by Lottery
and as I as I have explained the
lotteries when the lottery goes on
everybody cries people cry when the kid
gets in and they cry when the kid
doesn't
uh last year we had 80 applicants for
eight spaces now I took economics 401 at
the University of New Hampshire a long
time ago
supplying demand rules have not changed
they have not changed what had uh one of
the reasons that we only had eight spots
is because of the uh I think it's in the
legislation is that if you have a
sibling in school
this the new sibling jumps a line
because it makes sense not to have kids
going to different places
17 siblings join our school if that's
not a testimony that we are providing an
education that parents like I think it
is
what happens to Polaris
our electric bill goes up
our heating bill goes up our salaries
have to go up we're in competition every
day with the public with the traditional
Public Schools
in terms of salaries and here's the
place that we have no shot of of making
the equal we can't provide the benefits
to the public schools too we can't
provide the level of health insurance
for a teacher and their family we can't
provide the retirement benefits to do so
we always we always lose a spectacular
teacher
to the regular Public School System we
lost to win last week who got a
tremendous deal from the city of
Manchester and she was a great great
teacher so we we're in competition
without additional funding we're really
in tough shape for competition we have
to find people who
who believe in our mission
and can afford to believe in our mission
in terms of
benefits so I would strongly support the
bill
I will tell you about the success of the
Polaris Public Charter School we just
got recharged uh the second time so
we've been in existence for 10 years
I've been involved for about the last
four or five
we got recharted and the Department of
Education told some of the other people
that were charter schools to hang around
listen to this presentation see why
these guys are successful we fundraised
we've fundraised and thank you all very
much we fundraised through charitable
gaming
chair will Gateway 503c We Get
Charitable gaming money it's spectacular
because of the amount of terrible gaming
money and because our landlord a
wonderful man who bought the three
buildings from the Diocese of Manchester
knocked out knocked the steeple off the
church and put in offices and apartments
the rectory he refitted and gave
Denzel gave to Casa in uh in the public
school which was empty
when he bought it a high member of of
the diocese said to John elrico well
wouldn't it be great if this could be a
school again it is it's a great school
K-5 I hope you support it but because we
had the money and because we had such a
generous landlord we bought the building
we're here to stay we need your help to
stay but we are here to stay and I thank
you very much for your attention and be
glad to take any questions thank you
very much I do have a question for you
um within the statute you are able to
have had these fundraising type
activities to receive grant money from
various uh folks and organizations what
percentage of your budget is dependent
upon that money right now I'd say
eight eight percent nine percent
thank you are the further questions from
the committee
yes represent Woodcock thank you
chairman good morning thank you thank
you for taking my question uh welcome uh
sounds like a great success story uh is
there is there a theme or philosophy of
Polaris versus what is the
I brought the visual aid well but we
have a mission we would love to see him
but we have a mission another question
and the mission is which we say every
day before our trustee meeting
our mission is to create a joyful and
exciting Learning Community for
intellectually curious Elementary age
children through an engaging
inquiry-based curriculum our students
will develop the ability to communicate
effectively work collaboratively think
critically and Excel academically
our program Fosters creativity and
development of social emotional skills
instilling a positive attitude about
future studies and ensuring students are
well prepared for the challenges of an
ever-changing world and we do that
through a curriculum of project-based
learning okay that's another question
part of his mind okay yes yes sir if I
may thank you and then how many teachers
and your staff
about nine how many certified teachers
about half
okay thank you thank you chairman thank
you very much further questions from the
committee yes representative Cornell
Thank you thank you for taking my
question uh it's K through five where do
you know where they go for grade six and
Beyond or I don't
um I know some kids go to Founders okay
some kids go to creva some kids go back
into the traditional public school we
used to be K through six but with Middle
School Saturday at five we found that
it's better to have the kids start with
a new group rather than stay with us
thank you thank you further questions
from the committee not seeing you thank
you very much thank you I'd like to
thank you oh there we go sorry good
morning uh chair members of the
committee for the record my name is
Megan Tuttle if you're representing Nea
New Hampshire I'm the president for any
New Hampshire we represent more than 17
000 Educators across the state of New
Hampshire
um
I'll be very quick here I do have
written testimony to hand in
House Bill 272 institutes a 50 increase
in the portion of stadia given to
Charters that are approved by the State
Board of Education which almost all if
not all I think are run that way I don't
believe there's any Charters that are
locally funded or approved at this point
there were but I don't think there are
any more
our opposition to this bill just stems
from The Proposal being suggested is
that it's being suggested before we
solve other problems that we really
think need to be solved before this
should be instituted the National
Education Association issues a series of
rankings each year that it's among the
states in a variety of areas one is the
local Aid to States or I'm sorry the
state aid to local schools in the 2022
report as a percentage of school Revenue
New Hampshire once again ranked 49th in
the country for the 2021 school year
ahead of only Missouri and the least
amount of Aid given
this proposal we really just feel is a
little premature one of the reasons for
that and there's more in the the written
is we still have nearly 160 000 students
whose traditional Public Schools live
under that ranking of 49th and the state
eight that affects the communities most
adversely who struggle with poverty
we need to fix that before we start to
see changes to the state of poor state
board approved Charter funding figures
doing so if we were to fix that first
that would have the potential to help
our public charter schools as well as
traditional Charter excuse me
traditional Public Schools since they
both receive the base adequacy funding
in the same way
I'll take questions thank you very much
if in fact you see us passing
legislation which would increase aid for
the traditional public school system and
for the public charter schools would you
you get yes or no on that thank you
questions from the committee
perhaps I'm wrong
but it sounds like you're giving
preference to traditional Public Schools
as opposed to Charter Public Schools
they're both Public Schools I'm
wondering why you want to help one
before you're willing to help the other
we want to help both but they're funded
a little differently right traditional
public schools go through a lot of local
property taxes to get the extra funding
to reach the you know average amount of
nineteen thousand that it is to constant
to educate a child in New Hampshire
um raising the adequacy for both would
help both
so we do want to help both but they are
funded different so we need to fix the
funding system is what we believe
further questions from the committee
represent Belcher thank you Mr chair
um so this committee uh over this
session has heard testimony a number of
times about traditional public schools
that
um they're not currently adequately
funded where they're at and we need to
we need to do something to help them
um and without getting into the formula
itself just looking at the amount of
money schools are actually receiving on
a per pupil basis if my math is correct
it appears that Charter Public Schools
are receiving
at least half if not less on a per
student basis than traditional public
schools are as of right now so is it
reasonable to think that Charter Public
Schools can operate on that basis when
there's
clearly been testimony that regular
Public Schools can't operate on a much
higher funded basis thank you for the
question I don't think either public
Charters or traditional public Charters
or I'm sorry traditional Public Schools
can operate on the adequacy money given
to them by the state
and that's part of the issue is the way
the schools are funded doesn't work
neither one of the the types of schools
can operate or educate a child on 36
3700 that the state says is adequate the
other money that comes in is funded
differently some is funded by property
taxes Charter Schools do it through
their board through their budgets Etc
because they're approved by the State
Board of Education not by a local
district there were Charter Schools pace
for example was a locally funded one
I don't I wasn't involved in the
specifics I'm not sure why it's not in
operation anymore Charter Schools do
have the option of being funded locally
but to my knowledge none are but that's
up to the the towns or the cities to do
that
um so I don't think either one you know
they they all get the same adequacy base
rate and then additional on top of for
whatever Charter Schools do get
additional money per student then
traditional Public Schools get
traditional Public Schools get the tax
dollars so you know if we're talking
about just the state aid that goes to
them I don't think either one is
adequate I don't think either one is
adequately funded
thank you you're welcome thank you are
there further questions
not yes representative whitcock thank
you um thank you good morning guys how
are you uh how many teachers in public
school
uh the teach in the classroom how to be
certified and licensed all of them all
of them okay thank you you're welcome
for the questions from the committee
thank you very much thank you have a
good morning good morning Mr chairman
and members of the committee thank you
for taking the time to listen
um my name is Kimberly Lavallee I'm from
Mount Vernon New Hampshire and I'm here
to speak in favor of HB 272 I will try
not to duplicate what has been said
I currently serve on three New Hampshire
Public Charter School boards and the
constant question is what is our funding
going to be and how are we going to make
the budget work how much fundraising do
we need to pay the bills as everybody
knows we've been hit hard inflation's up
over seven percent we just switched
health insurance carriers for three of
the schools and that was to support and
attempt anyway to drive down the cost
and maintain quality benefits
73.38 this year is simply not enough we
just heard the schools can't
traditional Public Schools can't
function at over nineteen thousand we
provide everything with the exception of
the transportation and special education
is funded from the sending District we
handle the 504s everything else falls to
the public charter schools we are public
schools and we need to be able to take
care of our teachers our staff most
importantly provide the education follow
our mission that we've promised the
State Board of Education when we were
approved
I would like to touch on something that
hasn't been brought up but I heard it's
it's getting tossed around out there and
it came to my attention
the 10 lowest performing schools in the
state of New Hampshire included seven
charter schools and I know that's been
mentioned somewhere along the way and
other people are discussing it I think
it's worth noting beyond that headline
that five of those schools were created
to support students who are at risk of
dropping out or dropped out so I think
we should be applauding those schools
supporting those schools and more
importantly supporting the students that
attend those schools that have made a
commitment to go back and finish their
education and take an active place in
the New Hampshire Workforce which we all
know we hear about it we read about it
we're having trouble finding people so
just keep that in mind when you hear
those numbers five of the seven are
intended to support those students and
they're doing a great job
thank you thank you very much are there
questions from the committee
thank you very much thank you like the
okay good morning chairman lad and
members of the education committee I
want to thank you for listening to my
testimony today and uh I will not repeat
everything that's been said I'm here to
speak in opposition to HB 272 not
because of
um any disliker Charter Schools but
because it does not apply to all public
schools so if this bill were saying to
raise the funding for all public schools
I would be speaking in favor of it
um I want to be clear an extra thousand
dollars in adequacy Aid or grants to all
public schools would go a long way we
all have electricity costs heat and
costs benefits costs have gone up in
recent years and it is hard to retain
qualified staff to teach our students
and all of our students deserve a great
education
um as previous speakers have noted
there is
there are costs that remain with the
traditional Public School District even
when a student's family chooses to put
them in a charter school and they're
lucky enough to get the lottery
placement the traditional Public School
District still carries the cost of
special education in their budget they
still carry the cost of transportation
for students who live within the
boundaries of the district so when you
are comparing
the per pupil cost
in a district school to a charter school
you do need to remember that those
numbers stay with the Traditional School
District and just a couple more numbers
there are over 160 000 students going to
traditional Public Schools or
neighborhood public schools and there
are currently about 5500 going to
Charter Schools they all deserve a great
education and if we want to increase the
funding for all of them that is what we
should be talking about we should not
lose sight of those 160 000 students
to focus on just bettering one group of
students and that is all I have to say
that's why I'm opposing this particular
bill right now thank you very much are
the questions from the committee
represent I will take a question I don't
know if I'll have the answer
thank you very much
can you tell me what the average cost
per pupil of transportation and special
ed is
actually I do not have those numbers I'm
not going to try and and give you a
figure because I don't want to be
inaccurate I can do a little research
and look it up an average cost for
special ed is actually very
misleading because you can have special
ed services that do not cost very much I
understand doesn't mean much and you can
have specialized services that cost a
great deal because a student need to
highly specialize program such as
um you know one figure that leaves to
mind is the Perkins School for the Blind
um where it's in our district placement
and it can cost over a hundred thousand
dollars a year so it's going to vary
greatly and an average is misleading
um as for transportation I would have to
get some figures for you but I can try
and follow up on that thank you very
much uh just as a note uh we do have
Finance from doe here and maybe they
know yeah and what I'm saying to the
committee here if you have technical
questions such as that hold them off and
we you know write them down for yourself
and we can ask Mark at the end as to
that so I don't think you have to worry
about getting that information to us
okay we'll get in that other direction
yeah thank you through the questions now
see you thank you very much okay
good morning good morning chairman Ladd
and House Education members my name for
the record is Beth McClure I am one of
the founders and principal at strong
Foundations Charter School this is our
16th year and it's also the 16th year
that I've been principal and had to make
budgets
for our Charter School
our mission is to bring Orton Gillingham
education to all children in order to
improve reading scores and also to
incorporate the core knowledge
curriculum from Edie Hirsch so that our
students get a good solid background
in their education
we have a further mission to do Outreach
with traditional public schools and
private schools
uh to train teachers in Norton
Gillingham
I have done that and reached out and
trained teachers in over 20 different
District public schools in New Hampshire
we have a good relationship with our
districts and
um so I'm not trying to minimize what
the people who have been speaking in
opposition for the bill have said
however I think it's a false argument to
say that we need to wait
to increase the state contribution to
Charter Schools because that is all we
get we only get the same Aid because we
are Statewide we are unable to collect
any property taxes
when we are approved by the State Board
I would quickly Echo that it's very
difficult to hang on to teachers when we
cannot provide the benefits or come
close to the salaries that
the traditional Public Schools offer
make an offer to a teacher that I know
is a challenge for them to meet but we
do manage to hold on to our teachers
because they appreciate our mission and
we still do lose several each year
because we can't compete
so I would speak in favor of the bill
because that fifteen hundred dollars is
an immediate need
so that we can begin to hold on to our
that is the end of my testimony so I
don't duplicate
thank you very much Beth are the
questions from the committee yes
representative Myler thank you Mr chair
thank you for being here uh three
questions for you how many students do
you serve
what is your budget and how what percent
of that budget do you do in fundraising
thank you
we have a little over 320 students our
budget is about 2.5 million dollars
and we are
um a very only a very small portion of
our budget is through fundraising
because of the amount of work that we
put in just trying to run the school
thank you through the question represent
cordelli oh I'll pass them okay okay
next question are there further
questions from the committee not saying
thank you very much for coming today
um
good morning good morning and thank you
for letting me speak and address the
sport or committee I should say
um I wasn't originally going to testify
today but I find myself at a unique
position to do so
um my name's uh representative wood I
represent Merrimack District 13
Pittsfield and Chichester I served on
the school board in Pittsfield and I've
been trying to improve the traditional
public school for over 15 years being
involved with every board every
committee every asset of Pittsfield High
School a year ago I didn't know anything
about charter schools and I went from
there to being on the on the advisory
team starting at full disclosure
starting of uh Charter's Public Charter
School modern the Benjamin Franklin
Academy
uh during this process I've been uh
given the opportunity to uh visit
several uh charter schools and I want to
tell you they are amazing if you have
not been there you need to go to a
charter school and see the difference
and it's a huge difference
um
I said I want to talk wrong so I'll I'll
stick to that
um
I believe in bang for the buck I don't
I'm a conservative uh person I don't
believe in just spending money I work
through the budgets of a Traditional
School Board and I know what I can do
with 1500 uh dollars there trust me I
can do a lot more from what I've seen in
the uh Charter Schools is incredible
bang for the buck they haven't gotten an
increase the overall process is a huge
saving for the state and the sooner we
get people to understand that the better
I think the uh the state uh board that
did a really good job putting the
charter to I'm sorry putting the RSA
together that allows the start of a
charter school a public charter school
in there there's a provision to do
conversions of regular schools and again
this is outside I apologize this is
outside in the frame of this
conversation but I do suggest that the
board looks at uh the good that's been
done there how it translates to the
Charter School the flexibility we have
in putting Benjamin Franklin together is
amazing it's a flexibility I never ever
seen in the public school school system
so all the years I spent there so and
again I'm not again I'm a parent
um I wish I could say I was a papa bear
but uh not I don't come close to the
mama bears but um
I I do uh have a lot of experience with
the with the school system I have a PhD
I'm planning on teaching at Benjamin
Franklin without
um a certification because I'm allowed
to do it I have a PhD from MIT I think
it qualifies me to do to do that in both
physics and chemistry so these type of
flexibilities are definitely what the
state needs to look at and it's right in
your backyard there's over 30 of them I
think there's five more that would were
approved we were recently approved on
December 8th of this year the day after
I was sworn in so there were two amazing
days of my life so with that I'll open
my open my um this any questions and
again thank you for giving me the
opportunity this to address this board
thank you thank you are there questions
all right yes represent Allison oh thank
you Mr chairman thank you representative
for taking my question uh you mentioned
in your testimony the charter conversion
factor that that can be in play
converting a public school to a Charter
Public School is that the case of the
Benjamin Franklin Academy and are you
aware of any any schools in the state
that have transitioned from a public
school to a public charter school Under
the charter conversion uh it's a great
question and actually we're not going to
go there because that's off we do know
that Charter conversion we passed that
bill last year to change the process for
getting into a charter conversion we had
one that's no longer in the state so we
have no Charter conversions in the state
right now to answer that but let's stick
to this particular question which we're
dealing with the funding for
Charters please so we can get done we
have a number of cards left here
further questions
thank you very much we have another MIT
graduate on this board right here on
this Commission
but not here today but not here today
there's a vacant chair right I have
better when I he's not here today thank
you so much thank you very much Fred
Ward
that's it
oh is it
are you related to our senator
um we tend to hang out together okay
Senator Ward is chair senator
the um since an MIT degree is supposed
to be some thing I have three degrees
from MIT and I am having the biggest
fight of my life because I'm not happy
with what they're doing with education
so I have very mixed feelings about this
whole thing my name is Fred watt I live
in started I'm a meteorologist
I've spent a lot of time
a lot of energy and a lot of money
because I'm one of the founders of the
lionheart Classical Academy which we
started four months ago in Peterborough
now
I don't ever expect to get the money
back but I sure would love to get the
energy back if I could uh the front of
my six daughters
but that remains to be seen
I don't want to discuss money I'd love
to but others have done a nice job with
that I think that McDonald's we don't
have to have much of an argument I would
like to make one very important choice
and in many ways it's more important
than the money
what we're really doing here is to try
to even up
the way that public charter schools in
this sense compete with public schools
when we started this we were shooting
for 150 students and we were way
oversubscribed so we read it but raised
at the 200 students and we still are
oversubscribed
now I'll make the argument that we could
put more money into both the public
schools or in the public charter schools
or in private schools or whatever
but the most important thing here is
what we hear from the parents of the
kids who are sending them to our school
they loved the choice
are they making good choices I wish I
always made good choices I hope I made
mostly ones but my daughters would
sometimes disagree
this is not about money well it is about
money but in a sense it's not it's about
evening it up so that we can afford we
meet each other school people can afford
to offer to potential students at choice
it's up to them to make a choice
they may be right they may be wrong and
I certainly haven't made all my good
choices but I would like to have that
and I think that that's the only message
I want to have all of this is about is
evening up so that the parents of the
kids all of whom believe they're helping
the kids I certainly believe that but
they don't always agree
it's to help the kids and the parents
that have a choice I think that's the
key thank you thank you very much are
there questions for Mr Ward
not seeing you thank you very much thank
you very much
good morning good morning thank you Mr
chairman
um members of the commitment for the
opportunity to be here my name is Bob
Beth yeah
silver button there you go red okay
better sorry about that I'll start over
um thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee for the opportunity to be here
my name is Bob best I'm from Merrimack
New Hampshire
um I am also
um on the chair on the on the board of
several Charter Schools I'm the chair of
the board of the founders Academy in
Manchester and I'm the treasurer on the
board of spark Academy also in
Manchester and
um also worked with a foundation that
has been created to offer some knowledge
exchange among startups for charter
schools to know sort of how to how to
get things going and how to do all the
things that you need to do because most
of the time charter schools are
initiated by a group of parents who have
an idea and then they need a lot more
knowledge to convert that idea into
running a school
I am a big supporter of school choice
that's why I spend so much time I spend
hundreds of hours of my own time
volunteering for charter schools
offering to help them out all over the
place I also do some with my law
practice I'm an attorney at Sullivan
Hollis
um
but school choice is incredibly
important and it doesn't mean that you
have to choose a charter school I have
four kids they all went to the Merrimack
Public Schools and they all did fine
sometimes Public Schools traditional
public schools are the right fit for
students and sometimes they're not and
that's why one of the great things about
charter schools and the idea of school
choice is that for certain students you
can isolate and focus on a stem school
or a music-based school or a classic
based school or a history based school
and sometimes the classrooms are a
little smaller but always the focus is a
little bit more tailored to a mission
and you can have some success with some
students that might not have had success
in another environment I know there's
been a lot of discussion with sort of
the comparing casting of public
traditional public schools and charter
schools and
um I I'd like to avoid that a little bit
I don't know that it's an Apples to
Apples comparison the schools really do
quite a lot different things and and do
it in a different way
the the existing funding for charter
schools which all outcomes from the
state at seventy four hundred dollars
ish amounts to about forty one dollars a
day per student
um through the course of the year if
this bill passes that would increase to
fifty dollars a day per student
and I think that that should give you
some perspective on the value that you
get out of a charter school forty or
fifty dollars a day if you're gonna hire
a babysitter for your kid you wouldn't
get through the whole day on fifty or
forty dollars a day uh just for that and
to actually convert all of that into a
real education with teachers with
guidance counselors with all of the
other things that go on providing a
comprehensive curriculum as best you can
is real value real value in charter
schools
I think that to some extent we know that
we will have a different funding stream
than traditional public schools and to
some extent that makes us make uh uh
different and and sometimes good
decisions which are also learning
opportunities for the students so for
example if we try to offer a class and
not enough students sign up to make the
class go much in the way a college would
do we might have to change the the
schedule and not offer that class if
there's not enough people to to make the
class viable
um
and and for our students and our
community to realize that we're making
those kinds of value judgments and we're
spending the money as wisely as we can
is important
sometimes we have campaigns for supplies
uh copy paper is donated to the school
all the time
because it's part of what's necessary to
support it parents that donate school
supplies and all those kinds of things
and although we'd love to be able to
have a little bit of extra money for
those things the campaign to the
community that says we want and need
those donations is important and it
shows them again that we have a value
for how we spend and receive their money
but nevertheless as much as we can learn
from being Frugal and being as efficient
as possible
we still are in a place where the budget
and the financing is very very thin
we're not able to pay our teachers
comparable to what a traditional public
school or a private school would do we
don't offer the same kind of benefits
that they do although we do our best to
provide benefits it isn't as it isn't
equivalent we don't have the same broad
array of classes that are available in
other traditional public schools and
even just sort of basic science
equipment I can remember we had a donors
choose Campaign which is sort of like
GoFundMe but for a different different
Source but if donors choose campaign to
have some science equipment we wanted to
have a seismograph in our school and a
teacher you know showed the initiative
and went through the effort of doing it
and those things are great and they're
real successes for the community but at
the same time I think the School of
Public School a lot to be able to buy
its equipment for its science labs and
and its classrooms and things and be
able to afford it
um I don't have a whole lot more to add
to the discussion than that I I know
that again there's been some comparisons
between traditional Public Schools uh
they're fantastic and we would never you
know show up and listen and weigh in on
a funding bill for them and say you know
don't vote for it
um they're the right choice for certain
students and charter schools are a great
choice every student in New Hampshire
should have a choice right if this
school isn't right for them they'd have
another opportunity to try something
different
so that's my testimony here today I'd be
glad to answer any questions that you
have if you have any thank you attorney
best representative cardelli
uh thank you Mr chairman uh thank you
attorney best for being here
um I was wondering um about the
financial stability of the two charters
you're involved in
um as my first question sure so uh
Founders Academy has a fairly strong
financial position because it's gotten
to the point that it's got 430 to 450
students and a budget of over three
million dollars but nevertheless
um there's uh constant pressures I know
that um throughout education not just in
charter schools but throughout education
Cove had put a tremendous amount of
pressure on teachers there's a a huge
shift in teachers leaving the profession
and so you've got to do something to
take pressure off of teachers and all of
those initiatives that you would take
would cost you some money and when the
budget is all used up you really don't
have the latitude to do those kinds of
things so I don't think that the school
is in Risk in risk of closing but but
every year there's more and more
struggles with how do you find a new
teacher because one of your teachers
left retired or left teaching altogether
that sort of thing spark Academy the
other one is a lot different spark
Academy is a partnership on the campus
of Manchester Community College where
students will get college credit while
they're going through high school and
it's a much smaller student body and it
relies heavily on private fundraising I
think that they spend something like 11
or 12 000 per student but only have 7
300 from or 7 400 from the state so the
rest is Gap filled with private
donations and the school has to dedicate
a lot of time to that so thank you
follow-up question uh thank you
um
I'll maybe I'll ask about Founders
rather than uh Sparks but
um what would be the impact
on the
um local public schools and the
taxpayers if let's say Founders were to
run into financial difficulty and have
but hypothetically when a when a charter
school closes
um the the State Department of Education
would probably be involved as early as
they could be to try to create a soft
Landing for however that played out so
that it wasn't immediate or abrupt but
let's suppose it was abrupt and you know
you realize you can't make payroll we're
closing in four days
all of those students have to be pushed
back into the traditional Public Schools
transferring records finding schedules
and reintegrating into those schools
Founders Academy draws from 20 20 towns
mostly Manchester but 20 towns
surrounding it and I'm sure it would be
quite an impact on them obviously their
funding system is what it is and they've
got taxing Authority and federal funds
and state funds and I don't really even
understand their funding formula
completely so I can't really comment on
what the financial impact might be good
about or otherwise thank you represent
miler
thank you Mr chair thank you for being
here and presenting your testimony just
two questions uh first what is the
curriculum for Founders one and secondly
of the budget how much of that is
through fundraising thank you sure
absolutely so the curriculum Founders is
a as a a classical uh education model
with a focus on studying the the
founders that are mentioned in the name
it are the founders of our country
um great men and women uh in history and
learning through classical education
focused on leadership and character and
those sorts of things very civics-minded
school but it also has you know computer
classes and science classes and all
those kinds of things as well because
you need to these days
um let's see your second question was
fundraising how much fundraising
um it has been actually a bit better uh
recently but it probably ends up being
around 40 or 50 000 a year on a three
million dollar budget so it's less than
10 percent
um actually it's less than
five percent or a couple percentage
points anyway not doing my math in my
head I don't have the MIT degree I guess
Tulane isn't the same
thank you representative cascadden
uh thank you um representative Vlad and
thank you for your presentation as well
as the other presenters
um just inform the committee before I I
don't know if you're the right person to
answer my question but I did serve on a
public charter Board of Trustees for
four years and actually presented at
National Conference on its successes in
the North Country Charter Academy which
representative Vlad is very familiar
with was actually formed and opened by
public school superintendents but the
superintendents in the school districts
do not operate it it's independent so
it's a very different model but my
question is charter schools have
different grade levels and I don't know
how many
um have the high school level program
and if you know that number or somebody
knows that number what is the percentage
of the graduation rate because
graduation at a public charter school is
probably the one of the most exciting
days of the year because those kids did
not succeed in traditional public
so I don't know if you have that
information I know that both of the
charter schools that I'm on the board of
are are have a high school spark is
entirely high school and Founders is
fifth grade through 12th grade and so it
has a high school and I don't know what
percentage of all charter schools are
high schools versus middle schools and
elementary schools some of them are as
much as K-12 or at least they have the
ambition to be but you're right
graduation day is a pretty fantastic
thing and one of the real privileges
that I've had from being involved in
charter schools as the chair of Founders
Academy is every single diploma we've
issued has my signature on it I sign a
lot of things I'm a lawyer I'm a
planning board member there's nothing
more important in the world than signing
somebody's diploma for them this year
Founders Academy has 14 seniors and I
think when we did our board meeting two
weeks ago we have a wall where we show
the colleges that they've been accepted
to 20 college acceptances for the 14
students so far and we're still working
on it and so fantastic results for that
I don't know if I've ever calculated
whether our what our graduation rate is
I'm sure it's close to 100 because I
can't think of too many students who
have gotten that far and didn't succeed
maybe one or two here and there but um
it's a very high graduation rate and a
lot of success getting into colleges
um and and for some Charter Schools
Founders Academy included we don't
necessarily insist that a college is the
only path for somebody if career or
technical education is the right thing
for a student that's a victory and a
success too
thank you thank you for the questions
representative
thank you super Spock Academy yes uh how
many students about
uh let's see it's got its senior year
this year it's probably about 60 to 80
something like that students these are
all
manager
yes go ahead thank you these are all uh
youngsters who have at some point
dropped out of the public school you
said either at rushes no these are not
dropped out from public schools these
are students who've chose to to come
there based on what spark offers but
it's a very stem based school on the
campus of Manchester Community College
okay I'm sorry I thought I heard you say
it was an at-risk school okay thank you
thank you
further questions for
thank you very much thank you all thank
you for the chance to be here and um I
guess I didn't say the one thing that's
most important is I support this bill
excuse me can you yeah yeah there you go
can you hear me now oh yes okay my name
is Jen Cava
um I am from New Boston I'm here uh much
to my own surprise uh had not expected
to speak
um today on uh on in support of this
bill
um but I think if I didn't it would be a
missed opportunity
and I would drive away regretting
I am the daughter of two Public School
teachers
I have a decade of teaching and
traditional
Public Schools all over New England
middle schools and high schools I'm a
certified teacher I'm a certified school
principal
and I'm also the director of the academy
for Science and Design
I have been the director of the academy
for Science and design
chartered public school for the last 12
years
ASD is in its 16th year of operation
we are a stem focused School
serving students in grades 6 through 12.
we serve students from
29 different communities
seven percent of our kiddos are English
language learners
14 of our kiddos are on a 504
accommodation plan
and we also have I believe five percent
of our students are on special education
students
so we are
um
54 of our school is non-white
the reason that I bring up those
demographics is because ASD also
um is
listed as the number one school in New
Hampshire middle school and high school
by U.S news and World Report and that's
one metric right but we've also
demonstrated success
using a lot of other different rubrics
like the National Blue Ribbon award from
the U.S Department of Education the
Eddie School of Excellence given here in
New Hampshire
yeah our school has a very
um
dedicated mission
to engaging inspiring and nurturing
young people to pursue careers in
college and stem and Science and
Technology
and
so the lens that I want to speak with
you about
in addition to all of the the funding
models and the discussion that goes
along with all of that is
um
the fact that we're running a highly
successful
stem Focus Charter School
that has a role in this state to help
improve the stem Workforce here in New
Hampshire
that's something that I think we can all
agree is a very valuable and important
thing for us to be doing
I
just returned from a a board meeting I
sit on the national Consortium of
secondary stem schools it's a national
board a National Organization where all
of these leaders from all of these stem
schools come together and they talk
about what they're doing in different
parts of the country it was very
insightful
because one of the first things that
jumped out at me was the tremendous
disparity
in the amount of money that these
different schools charter schools
public charter schools private schools
and so on and traditional schools all
around the country that are focused on
stem our school was at the very very
very bottom
of of the of the pile in terms of the
amount of money spent per student
and that's a significant issue
um running a stem school
um on 7 300 something dollars
um is really challenging
um we can't put the materials in the
hands of the kids that they need to do
the work that we all want them to be
doing so that they go off into college
and and career and build great great
um
yeah
we have been successful
um in in doing the work that we've been
doing with our kids
and people will say well geez if you're
all you know if you if you were able to
be that successful with the amount of
money that you're currently working with
and why do you need more and I would say
to you that the reason that we have been
successful is truly we are running a
passion
you're running on passion
we we don't have
um the the funding to to Really
um support our teachers so I see them
you know leaving our school and and
going off to do second jobs and third
jobs and I know that's not unusual to
Charter Schools the same thing is true
um you know for all of our Educators all
of our our Public School teachers
um
but we're doing so without even really
being able to offer competitive salaries
even as compared to a public school
teacher in a traditional District
um
they don't really have a retirement plan
just that alone
asking those individuals to come in over
50 percent of whom are certified
teachers and I believe very strongly in
you know in continuing that work we have
a lot of teachers who are in the
pipeline who came from industry who are
interested in becoming uh certified
teachers here in the state
um but it's very hard for us to hold on
to them it's very hard for them to hold
without without uh without even being at
a competitive salary level to a
traditional public school teacher
um
our families are running on passion
because they have to tolerate
fundraising emails from me all the time
um
they have to come in to sub for their
kids classes well they don't have to but
they choose to right so we're able to
make a lot of things work because of
passion
our students
we have classrooms that are don't have
walls
we added doors to some classrooms a few
years ago over Christmas vacation and
you would have thought that you know we
that they were the hallways were lined
in Gold everybody was so excited
um but we we've asked our students to
also kind of run on this passion
and to deal with shared equipment at a
level that is is we've had to say no to
kids who want to do really great senior
projects because we can't afford to put
the tools in their hands
so this what I believe to be a
reasonable modest increase would be a
game changer for our school
and so thank you for hearing me thank
you very much are there questions from
thank you Mr chair and thank you for the
work you're doing because obviously it's
having an impact uh two questions one
what I've asked others uh what percent
of your budget is through fundraising
which you've mentioned and also would
you outline uh the Partnerships that you
have with industry particularly on your
particular school thank you absolutely
so we run on about a 3.8 million dollar
budget we're serving 525 kids
um we are actually approved recently to
actually expand to a fifth grade program
in the fall so we're excited about
getting students at an even younger age
um involved in in stem education
and our
fundraising percentage is about just a
little under five percent we bring in
anywhere from about a hundred and fifty
thousand to two hundred thousand dollars
on a good year uh closer to two hundred
thousand dollars and those are mostly
there's some grants associated with that
and then also just family giving and
corporate giving so
um the the second part of your question
thank you for that
um a huge part of our strategic plan is
our corporate engagement
we look to
um so a hundred percent of our graduates
complete an internship
and and very often in some type of stem
field so we have
um you know we have students who
um you know a lot of students who
complete internships through Bae I mean
Bae is incredible
um in terms of of the programs that they
have established that serve charter
schools and traditional district schools
and private schools they're a model to
follow I think in a lot of ways but we
also have you know the the local
veterinarian who has kids assisting with
surgeries you know the local dentist
who who came in and saw a need for uh
our students to have he's a chemistry
guy and so he built a lab for our
chemistry students
we do a tremendous amount of Outreach
to several local
businesses to have people come in to
present to our kids
um you know anything from the you know
the the physics of fountain pens
um to the science behind elections so
there's a lot of a lot of people who we
can get in to to work with our students
and and and do that sort of thing the
next phase is really to formalize a
process where we're able to get
information from
our local industry leaders to find out
what skills and talents they want to see
in in their Workforce coming up so we're
working on that now with our academic
committee to start building that
relationship before we go on with more
questions we're going to lose the
technical support from the Department of
Education if we don't get them up here
quickly they have to be in finance right
now
and so
um are there any more questions for the
current president yeah
represent Allison thank you Mr chair and
thank you so much for being here two
quick questions that relate to uh
feeding students do you know what
percentage of your students would
qualify before you reduce price lunches
under the U.S department of Agriculture
guidelines into how you handle feeding
thank you for that uh so right we um we
send out at the beginning of the school
year just like every other school a
request for students to report on free
reduced lunch
um we are very aware that there is
um a need for a group of our students
um I I would say we are probably at
about oh gosh probably like three to
three percent maybe three to five
percent of our students who are
reporting is free reduced lunch that's
the official number
um the real number the real day-to-day
number
um is we have
um several other students that we just
provide lunch for because we know that
there is a there is a need we have
students that you know so if I were to
that I would say that that number would
would increase
um you know we probably have uh
20 to 30 students who we're providing
things for
um you know anything from a laptop
um you know we have a great program
through the United Way in Nashville so
we're able to to take care of some of
our kiddos that way we have served a
couple of homeless students in the past
I would say that it is
um
it's something that we that we
feel very strongly about making sure
that those kids have equal access to
everything
um so if it's a field trip they're on
the field trip you know yeah thank you
very much thank you Mr chairman you're
welcome thank you very much for your
presentation presentation today thank
you very much yep I'd like to call
forward the department uh of Education
for the for the record Mark Manganiello
Department of Education Office of school
Finance I'm here if anyone has any
questions and needs technical assistance
representative leckis
thank you for coming forward to answer
my question
um so we've heard that the difference
between a traditional public school and
a Charter Public School is that the
traditional public the sending that the
resident District still has to pay for
transportation and special ed and but we
also know that there's a lot of special
ed that's covered by the state and other
things so I'm wondering what the if you
know what the average cost for that
transportation for transportation for a
traditional public school and the
average cost that a traditional Public
School actually pays you know from the
school as opposed to by the state for
special ed
a dump off the top of my head have a or
maybe I could do some quick math on the
sped state revenue versus local Revenue
but um I'll I'll just give you a couple
numbers
um
uh just some really rough math
transportation is about a thousand
dollars per student
um getting into the details and coming
up with the methodology that's really
precise is challenging because we have
to we would have to know all the tuition
agreements and which one's sending and
do a lot of analytical work to go is
this cost necessarily associated with
with this student and is the student
moving there so I just did a rough math
of what is the district spending on
Transportation first the students they
serve but it can get a lot more
complicated than that but for a ballpark
figure a thousand that's all I need is a
ballpark for special education
um we talked a lot about how special edu
Education costs can vary one particular
particular student can have low needs
and or one particular student could have
high needs but on average the state
spend in District Public Schools is 27
000 per student okay
um as far as Local 27
000 27 000 per student in a sped student
uh I'd have to do some more math to say
how much of that is State money Federal
money or local money um I can I believe
I've done that analysis before I just
don't have the top of my head thank you
Marco follow-up to that um are you
including in the special it costs uh the
old cat Aid
yes this is the expenditure side not the
revenue side so it include
uh yes includes all expat expenditures
so even even sending to a placement so
then we're really putting the high-end
250 000 hour student into this average
correct okay thank you for the questions
yes represent Balboni
yes thank you chair and thank you Mark
for taking my question
um there's been a lot of talk about the
state funding formula the adequacy and
just for my own Clarity when I'm trying
to figure out is what is exactly the
difference between the amount of money
that would be given from the state to a
traditional uh Public School versus
so that is a lot of different ways to
answer that question
um so there's kind of a uniform
funding formula for each Charter that
uniform funding formula is the for
fiscal year 24 it's going to be 3
866 dollars in base Aid a charter is
getting that base Aid also a district
school is getting that base Aid then we
have the differential Aid which is
additional add-ons if the student's fnr
sped ell third grade reading but just to
do apples to apples and it's hard to do
apples to apples when you're talking
about Charters and districts but to do
our best
um uh the base Aid is equivalent across
across uh in the funding formula for
both Charters and districts then
Charters have something called an
additional Grant which this legislation
is looking to amend the additional Grant
when you add on the additional grant for
uh Charters and fiscal year 24. if we
talk about 23 it results in so base plus
additional Grant it results in
7338 per student
um and for fiscal year 24 it's going to
be CPI adjusted seven thousand four
hundred dollars so seven thousand five
hundred dollars is kind of the not
dealing with demographic information
that is the base Aid and additional
grant for Charters now when we look at
districts it really depends on the
community so all districts are getting
base aid for educating students but some
districts have it gets very complicated
some districts have stabilization grants
some districts have relief Aid some
districts have extraordinary needs Grant
some districts have
additional select Revenue
um that goes above and beyond the cost
of an adequate education when you look
at the whole Statewide picture for all
districts on average the state aid per
pupil for all districts is around 6 000
I don't have the exact number but it's
around six thousand it's less than that
7 500 but it really varies so some
districts have
I think we could talk about Waterville
Valley uh I don't know what the number
of them yeah a really a large number 40
000 because their excess swap forty
thousand per pupil and some districts
are closer to that four thousand dollar
number
follow up uh just a quick follow-up so
basically so the money from one student
in say my district is getting going to
the Traditional School that amount of
money isn't exactly the same if that
same student decided to go to Charter
School correct the state funding would
represent uh Myler thank you Mr chair
and thanks Mark for being here just a
simple question
in the fiscal note it notes that this if
it were to pass was a 7.5 million
increase uh
what it doesn't deal with though is that
if within this year you have more
charter schools that are opened up which
is the goal of the Safe Water education
uh that figure then would be much higher
if in fact additional Charter Schools uh
this is the number used to get up with
that to get this number is the first day
counts for the start of school year 23
so if in fiscal year 24 uh Charter
enrollment increases then this number
would increase
representative Tanner
thank you and thank you for taking my
question
um public the district public Community
public schools are responsible for
providing transportation for Charter
Schools
um how much money do you think is on the
average that a district school I mean
that would be hard but let's say a place
like Manchester what do you think they
they're putting forward for
I don't have that information but I can
representative Belcher
thank you Mr chair
I'm just wondering what the uh the
Department's position would be on if we
look at the Supreme Court decision on
which these adequacy funding formulas
were based if I remember correctly the
exact wording in the Supreme Court was
something the effect of the
the calculation will be based on funding
from both state and local monies
um so when we're looking at Charter
Public Schools that are being funded
currently just out of state funding and
then similarly with efas would it be the
uh opinion of the department that we are
within the bounds of that Supreme Court
decision
despite the fact that there's no local
money being mixed in with this it's only
state
I'm not aware of that particular
question that particular
constitutional question involving
Charters coming up and so I'm I can only
rely on case law that's been codified so
and I'm also not a lawyer so I can't
really opine on that
um at all but I'm not aware of any case
law that really would help guide you in
the right direction into understanding
that whether there's a problem there or
not or legal risk or not thank you
further questions of the department
Nazi thank you very much Mark have a
good day
we have one card left here it looks like
George
you're gonna have to help me with your
nah that's okay
okay all right okay thank you welcome
thank you thank you for giving me an
opportunity
so my name is Jorge Santana
can you turn the red button
thank you there we go can you hear me
now yeah all right uh so my name is
Jorge Santana
um I am a clinical uh social worker by
trade and I have been doing macro work
which is doing um designing programming
for young people and families for over a
decade now
I came up to New Hampshire uh to turn
around a charter school that I worked at
for three years and I'm currently now uh
working on starting a new Charter School
and we've talked a lot about uh numbers
but I did just kind of want to talk
about young people and families for a
couple of minutes
um and I'm happy to answer any questions
afterwards
I guess for you know just in sharing a
little bit
um I did not have a great High School
experience I had experienced some trauma
and had no other option there was only
one game in town and that resulted in me
dropping out of high school
uh fortunately later on found out uh
found another uh program and uh became
the first in my family to graduate
college and then to go on and get a
master's degree so I just want to say
that um for me uh really again we've
talked about choice but I would just you
know put the idea out there that in a
lot of places in our state
you only have one option so if you've
been assaulted
um physically sexually
um if you have been bullied if you have
had a number of reasons which I was
dealing with with young people who were
coming to my school you are forced
to stay in that environment and if you
choose not to go
the state can be sent to your house to
force you to attend
and I just think that when we talk about
young people families we do talk a lot
about dollars but we don't talk about
those experiences that Force families to
look for another option or choice
uh the school that uh came up to turn
around I when I left we had a 54 of our
students uh where a special education
students
um and uh it was a very high number and
it was honestly because
we were able to support those young
people and what happens is
more people start telling others that
they're getting the support that they
need and they come
I'd also point out that in a lot of ways
you know we say public charter and uh
Public District school
but as a charter school
I had to accept students not only in my
district but I was sitting in but from
all over the state
so in a lot of ways I feel that you know
we were actually opened uh to a lot more
young people and families I had young
people and families who drove for over
I also wanted to talk about my
experience with special education which
we've touched upon
um
the resources are held at the district
level
which means that I had to advocate
each sending District
that each young person or family was
coming from and I will tell you that
there's no uh
you know a clear way it was a different
experience with every single district
and
I had to provide in the moment the
support and that those young people
needed because I couldn't say to them I
need to wait until this gets sorted out
with the district
so we had to provide that while also
managing that relationship with not just
and I also just wanted to talk a little
bit about the fact that district schools
also Bill Medicare
and there's a whole different Revenue
Source in there as well so there's a lot
of funds that come into for young people
and families around special education
and the districts serve really as the
gate uh Keepers to be able to access
those
and with uh Transportation you know for
the rule of thumb is that if the Local
District
provides transportation for young people
and families then they do have to also
support charter schools in that
Transportation but if they do not
provide transportation for a lot of our
rural schools for example then they do
not have to pay or transport charter
school students my students used to walk
for miles to get to my school we have to
buy a bus because I was worried about
them working walking on a highway
um
and you know so I think that um just
really being able uh to provide
um that support when even we think about
that
the probably number one
um engagement into the Juvenile Justice
System comes from referrals from schools
we should really think about the other
impacts that not having an opportunity
to choose or another option how that
ripples across the community as well
foreign
thank you for your time thank you very
much Jorge for your insightful
presentation are there questions from
the committee yes representative
thank you Mr Aladdin thank you for being
here what Charter could you tell us
which Charter School uh you're with and
how many students and what is a budget
for the that you're charged uh the
charter school is now closed
um when I uh started with the school
that had 14 students when I left we were
up to 82 students
um it was a school that was really used
as a last resort by a district
my students arrived at my doorstep as
Juniors and seniors with one to two
credits
the year that uh they closed the school
down the district I had 20 freshmen for
the first time ever the school had
freshmen coming for around the support
rather than it being used as a last stop
um yes so is your school part of a
Public School
program it was a sponsor it was
sponsored by a district but again it's
no longer in existence and where was
that in this thing uh it was based in
Pembroke thank you very much yeah
further questions can I see any thank
you very much thank you enjoy the rest
of your day yeah same to you so this is
uh the end of our pink card so we're
we will take a five minute break here
for committee members to stretch a
little bit and then we'll start up as
thank you for super simple reason for
why they close
yeah
foreign
okay we're going to go ahead here and
start the next bill we're running really
late here but we have HB 578 up on the
docket establishing the position of
reporting administrator in the
Department of Education
and the sponsors plural are not here so
would you please introduce the bill
this is what we do when we have nobody
showing up so we we have it scheduled
the public does come for these things
and that there's not a sponsor we
we make a sponsor represent cordelli
uh thank you Mr chairman and honorable
colleagues uh for the record state
representative Glenn cordelli
representing Tuftonboro moultonborough
and Ossipee in the beautiful Lakes
Region and I would like to introduce
House Bill 578 established in the
position of a reporting administrator
within the Department of Education
this position
would be a typical employee position and
it would be involved in establishing
Implement policies and procedures
templates and other needs at the
department for reporting requirements
and we are all familiar with the
reporting requirements that we
uh mandate for the department
so that is an ongoing need at the
department and the reason for this
legislation thank you very much
so Caitlin are you going to be available
for us from the Department here at maybe
to
good morning for the record Caitlin
Davis from the Department of Education I
feel like I might actually be the
sponsor of this bill
um so representative moffatt kindly put
it in on my my behalf but him and I were
having a conversation and he was looking
for some data on some reports that had
passed over the last several years and
some requirements for the Department of
Education to collect and Report various
different information from school
districts and I said frankly I would
love to give you that information but
the department has not had the time to
prioritize that work over additional
work that the department has that either
has state or federal requirements that
are more important or have more
consequences than that specific report
him and I were having a conversation and
I kind of said well you know another rep
just asked for this report we're doing
this right now X Y and Z and so I asked
him I said you know know the department
is we really would like to comply with
these reporting requirements we
understand a lot of the legislation why
it's passed why you're looking for that
information why you want school
districts to do X Y and Z but we just
don't have the capacity to really put
together some of the work required for
implementing some of these requirements
an example that a really tangible
example and a most probably the probably
the most fresh example in most people's
minds is sb420 so sb420 passed this past
summer and it started in the senate for
Extraordinary needs grants to provide
additional funding to school districts
that have a high proportion of free and
reduced lunch children to a low
equalized valuation so those grants
initially started going through the
Senate and then there was an amendment
to that bill to require the Department
of Education to collect an
accountability report from school
districts that receive this additional
Grant
so that bill passed that way without
additional reporting requirement and if
the the way the grant works is that if
you don't receive or don't do that
report as a school district then you're
not eligible for those funds
so this was in the summer that it passed
the Department of Education has to
um give estimates and school funding to
school districts a prior year so that
Grant wasn't even included that so there
was a lot of logistical
um work that we had to do explaining to
school districts exactly how to take on
this additional money how to account for
the additional money we then needed to
develop templates notify schools how
much this new additional grant that they
were going to be receiving outside of
their typical budgeting process was how
to do the reports
um when to get the reports to US
we then had to work with schools to make
sure that they understood the template
the reporting requirements the
consequences if they failed to produce
that report which is that they would now
if they failed to reproduce their report
and failed to opt out of the additional
funding um to the Department of
Education by early fall then they would
have a revenue shortfall and then
therefore not have enough money for the
school year that they had budgeted so
there's just a lot of logistics that go
involved to go go that are involved with
doing this work I would say
it's all total the department has spent
since the since this bill passed this
past summer over a thousand staff hours
on this one requirement alone and those
the staff hours are not just one person
um those staff hours are I.T staff
pulling together the data that's
required for
um the assessment information other I.T
staff that are required that are
required for the actual calculation of
the free and reduced lunch per
um per equalized valuation there are
accountability administrators right now
that work with schools to help them
understand accountability and assessment
results and are doing the communication
about what the appropriate
terminology and documentation required
in the plan are we then have training
hours for school districts we develop
training documentation for school
districts we have office hours for
schools to call in and ask us questions
on undoing these reports
we then have Mark who was just
testifying on the charter school bill um
talking to the business officials in the
school about what the financial
implications are because those are
different than the performance
implications of the reporting
requirement and then we have me working
with superintendents mostly explaining
them the requirements of the reports
working through
when we set our deadline for January 9th
to receive those reports calling schools
that said yeah you know you you missed
this so if you don't get it to us today
you're probably going to have a budget
shortfall this year and it's going to be
problematic and
this is what we do in our typical
process for everything we're trying to
make sure that we're providing really
good customer service to the schools
especially since it's a new requirement
and we're trying to make sure that they
have everything they need so that both
Us and Them can be successful so January
9th was our deadline for the report we
worked through a few late submissions
the end of the week last week we got all
of those in we do have one from every
single School District
which is exciting for the department now
we're going to be in the process of
taking that information redacting what
is necessary if they're to make sure
that there's no personally identifiable
data that's used in those reports and
now we're going to have to publish those
reports so this is just one of many
reports that are on the books
um a couple additional other reports
that you'll see listed
um in the bill is the gifted and
talented report that passed about a year
ago
um that was a representative moffett's
bill um that's why we're having this
conversation
um and I actually very recently said to
him we are working on that we did put
out the initial data collection and and
whatnot from schools but we need to do
follow-up we need to kind of work with
schools to get the additional
information that we need to work on our
reporting methodology to get it out of
our systems and onto onto an appropriate
place that's visible for the public
um but that there is no funding attached
to that bill school districts we're not
going to have issues with tax rates and
things like that if they didn't do that
so we chose to prioritize the other one
even though it passed more recently
because of the implications relative to
funding and tax rates
um another bill that's in here and I had
a recent request from representative
Hobson who is not on education this year
but she she reached out and she was
looking for a bill relative to
differentiated Aid and third grade
reading and adequacy that's another
report that the department has just not
historically done because we just don't
have the staff capacity to do that
report and so we
um would always like to follow all of
the requirements in the law book I
actually have a bill in finance right
now talking about the law book and
hopefully recodifying those laws
um but it's just one of those things
that we are looking for an additional
staff to really be able to focus on this
so we can ensure that we are really
complying with the laws that you have
written for the department and and
um
and so we can give you the information
that you're looking for but also make
sure we're providing good customer
service to the school districts when
they have to do this additional
reporting
take any questions thank you very much
Caitlyn representative Rock dry thank
you Mr chairman thank you
is this a full-time position this would
be a full-time position nice good
follow-up I asked this only because
yesterday we we saw a bill requiring
somebody
making a position for data analysis and
and just and and discussion with schools
and taking training to schools and a lot
of that overlaps with what you were
talking about here and wondered if we
could combine something so it depends on
what you want so you're the legislature
is always trying to combine different
requirements and that's how we are how
we are here now they're saying oh well
you already have somebody that does
assessment or work and you already have
somebody that does Finance work and you
Caitlin are already already talking to
superintendents about other things
um but
so we have enough reporting requirements
to occupy probably full-time three
full-time positions at least just in my
division and I'm not even talking about
the other divisions at the department
um so
then if the analysis and trading for
school districts is a priority that will
come after if you choose to combine the
two so we'll say all right let's look at
the reporting requirements that have
financial implications we'll work on
that and then we'll get to the other
part so we likely wouldn't be able to
get to the the additional art so it's
just a we can pick and choose what the
priorities are and if you want the
department to do both we probably
actually in fact need positions to do
both
represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair
um the bill itself I mean it seems like
it's probably necessary
but there was one
um item in your testimony that concerned
me just a bit and that was uh you had
said that you failed to meet reporting
requirements for some of the things in
law you didn't have the obviously the
Manpower and whatnot but you said that
you would
had to prioritize Federal requirements
so I'm I'm wondering if it's the policy
of the department to prioritize Federal
requirements or so it is not the for
Department the policy to prioritize
Federal requirements unless there's
federal grants that are dependent on it
so there's often times where a staff is
fully paid for the federal funding and
so it's not appropriate for that staff
person even though they might have the
expertise and knowledge to help with
some of the state reporting to
prioritize State work over Federal
requirements that's a requirement to
continue to participate in federal
grants so that's oftentimes when we're
talking about priority thank you
thank you Caitlin I have a question for
you
um
so it's
I'm starting to believe that a lot of
the responsibility for this is on our
shoulders the legislature for asking we
want reports on policies for this to be
submitted to you whether it be gifted
talented or whether it be recording
policies in the classroom
um
my concern though is there is any is
there a need for
more support
within the department for your present
staff and bureaus to accomplish the
mission and task that they have at them
for example like in in the Statewide
assessment is a mandate that comes down
as a result of Esser and as a result of
the federal requirement we must do
increase three through and up not grade
11 as well
um it's it we need to be able to
interpret that stuff
so there's a rationale I I believe
are we then asking you to do some things
that are not related to your current
responsibilities such as Gathering
policy
and it is
I guess I'll leave it at that because
there's a lot of other questions I have
which we'll get in with extraordinary
needs Grant when we talk about that
upcoming later this morning
so I'm not entirely I sure I understand
your question well we have
is it a priority of the department that
we be sending and forwarding to you
reporting policies regarding how we're
recording in the classrooms
how we're providing what we're doing
with gifted talented education are those
priorities for you
so I would say if you pass the law then
it becomes a priority for the Department
because we really do want to implement
the laws okay see that's that's where we
always go and and it's you know to me
you know for you to do what you're
tasked to do by way of Statute right now
okay okay
Caitlin I won't Crush you anymore oh so
I'm honestly I'm not familiar with that
bill I haven't been tracking that bill
representative Cornell
thank you thank you Caitlin would it
help when we're passing a policy Bill
like the gifted and talented which I
think we were assured would be no work
for districts or for the Department
because it was just going to go in a
folder that anybody could look at
whenever they wanted to so it was
supposed to be no work for anybody so if
when we were doing something like that
which we know is going to be work for
the school district and the department
to put in the fiscal note that along
with that policy there will be support
provided
monetarily for someone at the department
to be able to do it that would be
extremely helpful yes thank you further
questions representative
oh no no thank you very much Mr chair uh
and a question to the chair were you
just referring to House Bill 435 which
is the end of the day today
with respect to the the grant
no I'm not referring to I'm not I'm not
referring to the grants I know that for
example within 6 30 6 38 is one that I
think that was addressed here a second
ago by Caitlyn dealing extraordinary
needs and the reporting which we part of
the issue I think what she's and I might
be wrong but is the issue that we have
an accountability portion with it
written in that where in order to
receive it you've got to be accountable
for setting up a plan for using these
dollars and that is uh and we were
cautioned during that hearing not to do
that uh we I made that comment I I
understand you made that comment uh so
so that's where we are and then I think
we're hearing something that we need to
be cognizant of that that staff at the
doe is not fully funded the way we think
they are and in order to do this it's
going to take additional dollars and I I
think relative to your comment about
requirements from Essa versus state
requirements so there are certain times
where federal and state requirements are
aligned so assessment for account for
example the Assessments in three through
eight and eleven in math science reading
and
math science reading
um so those are state and federal
requirements so fortunately we are able
to use leverage the federal funds to
really pay for the majority of that work
and so the staff that we are kind of
getting a two for one deal the staff are
paid out of the Federal grant but
they're able to comply with the state
reporting at the same time because it's
exactly aligned but for example
extraordinary needs Grant is not aligned
there's no federal requirements that are
similar to this so we really can't use
those staff unless we have some sort of
either a time and effort which we're
breaking down building their time for
the state funding and whatnot and even
at that we have to be cautious of Staff
time
um and I know you know some of you have
been to well I guess all of you have
been to the Department of Education but
some of you have had the pleasure of
working with many of my staff one-on-one
at the Department of Education and
you're seeing a lot of them as we're
starting to go through this educate
through this kind of education session
here
um the staff want to do the best
possible job as they can they want to
comply with the laws that kind of
dictate the work that they're supposed
to doing be doing in their job
descriptions but when you have too many
things it really worries a good
full-time employee because they're
saying well I don't have the time to
focus on one specific thing and do a
good job of that and they don't
necessarily want to do a adequate job at
everything else
um and so in in especially in my
division under alternative you know
talk about the work that other divisions
are doing but
for 420 for example it put a lot of work
on Mark this year at the exact same time
that Mark is trying to set to to
calculate a billion dollars in adequacy
and set tax rates for every single town
across the state
so any time that he takes a second away
from that we could potentially make a
mistake calculating a tax rate and those
have implications for every taxpayer
across the state and so now either a
town has an issue and they have to do a
supplemental tax bow which that's not a
good thing
um or you know maybe they've raised too
much revenue and that it creates an
issue so it's just one of the things
that we really would like to focus and
do a good job on our work but we're
getting spread too thin for the capacity
and the amount of work that has been
added in the existing in the in in the
last several years so
thank you represent Myler
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
being here Caitlin as always
clarify for me please the difference
between
enacting a position in law
vis-a-vis a budget request from the
Department for this position for example
and clarify that crosses so the majority
of it is timing
um and so the Department of Education is
always given targets for budgets that
you're supposed to so you historically
well sorry all agencies are given
targets for budgets so you'll say all
right your budget is 105 of last year
for example and this is just how State
budgeting works so you look at 105 and
you say all right well within my 105
percent I have to account for raises or
anything like that new hires you hired
somebody this year who's on a family
plan who wasn't a who's the person
wasn't a family plan you have to account
for those and so those kind of limit the
amount of new positions you're able to
request but additionally so for this one
specifically the Department of Education
timing line or Statewide administrative
service Services has a process where you
request new positions the Department of
Education had done all of our position
requests in April you didn't pass this
bill until June and so it was too late
to request a new position for that and
we will continue to Advocate and we do
constantly advocate for new positions at
the Department of Education through our
budget process but a lot of times just
the timing doesn't line up and then
sometimes it's budget priorities don't
line up to from the various different
steps from you know from the governor's
office to the house the Senate you know
there's positions that you know usually
it kind of you know there's 20 positions
on this 10 positions and there's five
positions and maybe two end up passing
that's kind of been my historical
um yeah experience that it just it goes
down so it we have a process we do
follow that process but it's it it
doesn't necessarily always line up with
the needs yes so if I may try to
interpret what you just said that by
having a law passed creating a position
makes it then a priority ready to be
budgeted of which the department then
doesn't have to fall within that 105
percent this is outside the the existing
budgeting process yes and especially
when it comes with appropriation thank
you very much further questions from the
committee yes representative
thank you chairman thank you Caitlin
um I would imagine that office space for
more stuff would also be something we
might need to take into consideration I
mean
your the space you're using right now is
pretty nice but
I there's a limit I mean on how many
people you can put in the spot right
that is absolutely true oh space is a
concern um we are hoping to stay on 25
Granite seat and there is sufficient
space for the department needs right now
but I mean if we continue to grow I mean
that that same concern though is
relative to just all Department
operations
um so if we get a new Federal grant for
example and we have three positions of
tied to that Federal grant then we need
office space for them too so that's just
that is an ongoing kind of business
operations of the department
um but then when we're talking about
Federal needs and whatnot taking a
priority that's another good example is
so a lot of times we get all these new
federal grants and these federal grants
come with money and staff attached to
them and that's how we justify a
position and so then that's why the
federal work then takes priority over
State work because we have a specific
position that's coming from that Grant
to to do the actual goals of that Grant
and so if this were to be you know so
pretend extraordinary needs grants was a
federal Grant the Department of
Education would have written a plan
saying this is what we're going to do we
need a position to do this work we need
an administrative set aside X Y and Z
and then we would have operated it that
way but this is a state program so now
this we're following the state process
for this one
yes representative
thank you very much Mr chair and um and
I think well you know when we when we
get to the to the next bill we'll have
um you know opportunity I think for
robust discussion on on the
accountability requirement behind the
extraordinary needs Grant but um but
just sort of you know leading up to uh
to that and I think tied in with the
with this request
and
um and it's
um sort of dual purpose of both
collection and Reporting because I think
that's that's an important element
um of it that that you've spoken to and
you mentioned that that uh uh outside of
of this request it's consumed
approximately a thousand staff hours
just on the Senate Bill 420 yes
um uh collecting and Reporting
um you know piece of it so a thousand
Collective staff hours at doe is there
do you have a sense or what sense do you
have in terms of uh what impact that's
had on local school districts in terms
of the collective staff hours on putting
those reports together for the
Department yes so
I have not spoken to schools to gauge
exactly how many hours that they've
spent on this but I mean similar types
of hours I mean so school school
districts have to one understand take
some time to understand the implications
of this
um so that oftentimes for this one
required their business administrators
looking at that saying should we go to
this should we not
um school districts that wanted to take
this money and use this money in their
budget because it was received outside
of their regular budgeting process had
to do a special meeting so the costs
associated with doing a special meeting
and all of that time
superintendents or a lot of times
curriculum assessment administrators
were the ones that were preparing this
plan so they were the ones that wrote
the plan and submitted to the Department
of Education attended the various
different trainings hosted by the
Department of Education so it definitely
as expanded staff hours required by
School Districts as well fortunately it
does come with additional funding so the
schools can take advantage of that in
the future but not when you're doing the
initial application part process
okay great thank you very much for the
questions of the department yes
representana
thank you and thank you for taking my
question
um is there any is it is it just
duplication uh to have listing out
uh the different reporting things that
are already listed in other rsas
um in this build is it necessary or
could it just be set to coordinate and
develop technical assistance uh to
education yes that would be perfectly
fine I was trying to give the committee
some tangible examples especially when I
was speaking to representative Moffett
because and those were ironically those
were all examples that I had been asked
for in the last like week-ish of when we
had had our conversation I believe that
was a few months ago
um but
um yes you could definitely be more more
vague and that's kind of what we put
that other category on there because we
do want it to be others the only thing
is is I do know that those Grant those
reports are a specific priority so we do
want to make sure that we're doing
something to deal with that priority
thank you
further questions
not see any thank you very much thank
you
okay we have no other cards on this
particular bill so we're closing this
who's neutral
yeah
no if the the person introducing it has
to be pushed you know supporting the
nature of the bill you can't hook up
with my question yes yes because he's
not one of the sponsors or anything yeah
but he's acting on behalf of
are they committed to interviews that
bill so but you might put down a notes
that was introduced by a Committee
Member who has not taken a position on
the bill
but technically when you introduce a
bill and you're interested because you
yeah
okay
yes do you support could you support
um yes
a thousands
and say he's working inside
I think we'll
um proceed on to the next bill which is
House Bill 638 relative to the
extraordinary need grants to schools and
uh call on our chairman representative
Ladd for Testimony thank you very much
Representative cordellia members of the
committee for the record my name is Rick
Ladd I come from Haverhill New Hampshire
Grafton five I'm here today to introduce
House Bill 638 this is relative to the
extraordinary needs grants to schools
last year through the Senate bill which
came to US senator Hennessey was to
sponsor of that we had a bill for an
extraordinary needs Grant which was to
support those communities which had you
know need much like we've talked about
with equalized property valuations are
low and how can we assist when that bill
came to us it had approximately in it uh
15 to 17 million dollars we did have an
Amendment which we put onto it dealing
with differentiated Aid in terms of a
special education assistance so it would
have rounded out around 30 million
dollars going down to districts
unfortunately that part was pulled out
and the extraordinary needs portion
passed this bill addresses the issue
that
Caitlyn has just discussed with you
regarding the accountability section and
this accountability was added into the
extraordinary needs as a result of some
of the historical background we've had
when we've been dealing with new
components of differentiated Aid and one
of those components was put in during my
tenure here was the funding for the
remediation of a third grade student in
terms of language arts reading if in
fact they were not receiving
differentiated Aid and the other three
categories which we have English
language learner special education and
and
the um let's step fourth one here free
and reduced yes
so uh with that we had discussed earlier
with Finance many years ago how can we
have some accountability that the money
we're putting in for this this 600 or so
back then now maybe a little higher than
that for the that fourth category
differentiated I spoke to dealing with
the English language arts remediation
what kind of results are we getting back
for what we're what we're putting money
in for how are we seeing any gains uh
and growth well it's very difficult to
see growth when you're seeing you're
funding and only at one time and you
can't see the results of that coming out
of the third grade so I I believe within
the legislature there was a certain
level of frustration saying how do we
get accountabilities so that we know
that this money is being used a grant
you can put in requirements uh however
the way it's done uh the uh grant for
the uh English or for the remediation
into differentiated a it is not a grant
as part of adequacy so it can be used
that money can be used any way you want
to use it within the school district
so there are a number of legislators
which were you know frustrated over that
are we using specifically to help the
remediation and what are we doing give
us some examples
um we didn't get that and that's right
as I recall I presented this committee a
while back that there's the cohorts
remember how the grades were going and
we saw the waterfall effect in the
mathematics that was a result of back
though in those days
so the concept was when we passed the
extraordinary needs Grant we'll have
some accountability seeing this is not
part of differentiated this is on top of
it's a separate Grant and we'd like to
see how this money is being used now we
see that we have caused a problem from
the standpoint that we've caused all
this that Caitlyn's just explained of
time and effort and now we're looking at
additional Personnel to
provide us that data or information
where we're looking for in terms of all
the the the recent reporting which we've
asked for
and so this is puts us in that quandary
how do we get the results or the
information we need if the OE doesn't
have the staff to provide us that
information
so I guess that's where we are with the
extraordinary needs Grant I do concur at
this point in time that is very little
sense for us asking for a district to
show us how they're using extraordinary
needs Grant if they're receiving two
thousand dollars a year
that that's true in many of our very
very small communities as you go up that
scale they receive more money
um perhaps this was and I was probably
remiss in saying I would like to see
some accountability but I was probably
remiss also at that time even asking for
the accountability so you can chuckle
that representative luno in terms of uh
this aspect of this extraordinary needs
Grant because I for one have always been
a pusher for fiscal capacity Aid and
helping those districts which have the
poverty within we need to do something
and perhaps that was the wrong bill but
we're trying to get something passed to
get this money to the district so with
that you come out with all these add-ons
to get things through and it's again one
of the things that had to be done I
believe to get the the end result of
getting the additional 17 million
dollars
so that concludes my testimony
I can't really answer a whole lot more
other than what the Department's already
provide us I think we're going to be
very cautious and what we are doing in
the future in terms of the issue that's
just been brought forward by Doe uh
resident of Lucas
thank you
um I remember we asked for
accountability
don't remember exactly how it was worded
but looking at
so it's kind of a two-pronged question
one is are they telling us how they
spent the money
and if not I'm noticing this is get
asking them to give a plan
but they don't it seems like they don't
have to actually follow that plan and
how do we know whether or not they did
where this all came from us back when we
were looking at the adequacy formula
back in 2008-9 which
um that's the the group that put that
forward was Senator Estabrook she's no
longer in the house honorable Estabrook
we also had a component there where we
were we if you look back in the old
statutes you'll see where money was to
be used for certain areas of all those
input areas in base adequacy there
wasn't an accountability front plan that
was really presented to the department
but it was basically advice that this is
how it should be used the money should
be used I think that's where we got that
same concept for what we did last year
we're looking at trying to find out how
this money is being used but I when
Senator sbrook and Company were doing
they were doing with much larger dollars
than we're dealing now they're doing
differentiated a which is huge dollars
compared to what we have for
Extraordinary in each Grant and if you
take out the extraordinary needs Grant
spreadsheet which we do have and start
looking at the districts there's many
districts which is receiving uh
you know less than fifty thousand
dollars and that's that's you know we're
asking for all the time and energy of
Personnel in the school department to
put this together
I for one as a minister would probably
blow it off
and and I see another head going up and
down over there because it's just not
worth I don't have the staff to do it
there at the local level and and and if
I do have the staff the time I'm at the
additional time and costs don't equate
to what I'm getting back from this grant
so I think we've really got to really
look at this extraordinary Grant in
terms of what we're asking for the
concept is a good concept we need to get
money to districts now accountability
further questions
uh representative Cornell Thank you
thank you for taking my question is this
which which bill you talk about your
bill this bill right here
there's still going to be accountability
for those which are receiving additional
dollars more than 50
000 so yes there there is if
anytime you're going to have a grant of
any kind though you're going to have to
have staff Computing what District's
going to receive so it is going to cost
time but that's also why we have people
over there in finance at the Department
of Education
if we're going to be looking at
modifying our formulas in any way and
we've got a lot of bills where we're
trying to jiggle those Mark's going to
have to do some juggling around perhaps
we're going to change that for me a
little bit but that's expected that's
part of the job over there
and I I think the extraordinary needs
Grant and if you look at all we've done
from the original fiscal capacity
disparity Aid and the concept which we
had for establishing policy poverty back
in 2008
we've gone now and we we've changed how
we provide support for the poor
districts
I don't know how many times over the
last 10 years and with that every time
we make a tweak
representative luno
thank you very much Mr chair and uh and
thank you very much representative Ladd
for uh for submitting this uh this
legislation I think this is basically
legislation is put together
by the department yeah yeah
um but I wanted to I wanted to direct a
question particularly at um at at Part D
down at the down at the bottom and um
and particularly how that can uh can
give school districts confidence in um
in in the report that they provide uh uh
and uh you know not interfering with the
grant award but basically providing some
some heads up as to how districts um
well we're talking about unrestricted
funding here correct and that's
basically what we do with the other
monies which we provide through
education funding and I'm I'm closing on
that position right now that if we do
something like extraordinary needs Grant
based upon property values however we
may do a medium family income it should
be on unrestricted right right thank you
thank you and and that this clarifies
that's right so there are there are
there are some good points in this Bill
thank you
any further questions from the committee
see none uh thank you representative
[Music]
um
does anyone need technical support on
this bill from the Department
or did they
did the department want to uh testify to
any anything that has been uh mentioned
um we just have a little bit of data to
help explain what this bill is going to
do so this bill is not eliminating
um the extraordinary needs grants by any
means and it's actually not going to
create any additional work for the
Department it will limit some of the
work the department is doing and some of
the work that school districts are doing
because essentially this bill is just
putting a um a minimum requirement for
the extraordinary needs accountability
plan in place for schools so school
districts with a small Grant will still
get that Grant but they won't have to
spend a substantial amount of staff
hours working on that and the department
won't have to spend hours tracking down
a plan for maybe a 700 or 1500 Grant so
Mark has some actual data as far as the
number of schools that have submitted
plans and then the number of plans this
will eliminate
um just Market Magnolia Department of
Education uh just generally there's
about for fiscal year 24 I think 84 84
communities that need to do a plan and
then this will bring it down to 35 so if
um you know plans under 50 000 so these
would just be plans over 50 000 where
they can look at that growth data look
at that outcome data and submit it to
the department as required by law by the
existing RSA not what this bill does
um
the other thing just to go through the
bill a little bit a lot of it's just
sort of codifying we had when this law
passed this summer
um it was in effect for fiscal year 23
so we had to implement it pretty quickly
and so we had to come up with sort of
some policies and some understandings of
how to interpret the bill
um that summer and we had to communicate
that to the district so a lot of what
this is doing is just codifying our
existing understanding
um
um if you were not to pass this some of
the stuff would still hold true so it
would still hold true that all adequacy
is unrestricted even though it's
conditional on completing an
accountability plan it's still
unrestricted Aid and that was I spent
hours talking to districts about that
because they they are used to receiving
grants federal grants which are highly
restricted and there's a highly
restrictive process in which to submit
funds and receive that that is not how
adequacy works and I think this is a
concept that a lot of districts didn't
really understand is that adequacy
essentially underwrites your local
budget it it financially supports
whatever you're going to choose to do as
a community it underwrites it in every
single attitude adequacy dollar goes
against the tax rate so if that if
there's any error in any adequacy dollar
you are anticipating and setting the tax
rate that automatically creates a budget
problem
um so a lot of districts had to be had I
had to walk them through that and how
adequacy impacts the tax rate and so it
they were treating it like a traditional
Federal Grant and that was one of the
struggles so a lot of this is going to
clarify this so I can point to a
district that's confused and say look at
this bill look what this bill's telling
you
um it will hopefully make the TA a
further comments from the Department
um we're getting on where we are now 577
we're right on time
let's sleep you're going to make all
these things just unrestricted and be
okay we're gonna close in on the last
bill we have this morning that's 577.
this bill is relative to eight uh state
aid for special education pupils
okay
represent Thomas
good morning listen up yeah thank you Mr
chair thank you to the committee for the
record representative hope Damon
Sullivan District eight the towns of
Acworth Langdon Leinster Goshen
Washington Springfield Sunapee Court in
Claremont
something like that
um in really quite lovely saltland
County
um quite frankly I'm not expecting to be
the person to introduce in this bill
this morning I will do my best and take
it from there
um
it is as stated it changes the limit for
school district liability for special
education costs reducing it from three
and a half times the state average to
one and a half times
um
clearly the intent of this is to provide
more State funding for special education
it is prorated to districts if not
enough funding is appropriated
as has been the case for many years that
there's not enough special education
funding in the state budget
uh
there is an additional proposed 250 000
for special education funding in
communities of less than 1 000 students
and last night I said well how many
communities are there with less than 1
000 students there's 58 I mean I'm sorry
less than 1 000 residents I misspoke
there are 58 New Hampshire communities
that small
the special education amount has been
the same since 20 since 2007.
clearly nothing else is the same in
costs
so
I think I would just say special
education is extremely important the
cost to small communities of one or a
few
higher cost special education
programs
breaks the back of little districts I'll
use my own town of Corydon as an example
we are less than 800 people 650 or so
registered voters
have a cater for school and then tuition
our students to a variety of other
schools through a school choice program
the total number of students being
educated by Croydon is less than 80 in
one student
are in our total school budget you guys
are going to chuckle is a 1.7 million
dollars including the tuition for fifth
through 12th graders
one special ed student can alter that
budget
in a very very significant way and the
state is not doing its share
thank you
thank you representative Damon
um there are there questions for
representative Damon now understanding
that we will be discussing this in exact
session and the department is here and
she's standing in
for the prime sponsor so we'll stay out
of the technical questions please
represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair I just wanted to
clarify because your testimony was was
more to the effect of of single or small
numbers of students catastrophically
affecting budgets
but isn't this bill more in attuned to
the more the the smaller increases and
larger number of students because
it seems to me that
the current uh law the state is picking
up the overwhelming majority of the cost
for those catastrophic is that am I
I don't specifically know the answer in
terms of what amount of the catastrophic
costs the state picks up I know it's
significant
the bill doesn't only address that I was
just highlighting that part of the bill
the primary feature of the bill is the
changing the limit for school district
liability from three and a half times
down to one and a half
thank you and for clarification purposes
now if you take the average cost let's
say twenty thousand for an easy figure
three and a half times the district has
to cough up seventy thousand dollars
before they're going to get state aid
then up to 10 times otherwise the the
that per pupil cost the state will kick
in 80 percent of that difference right
there so again the local district has 20
percent they're added on to the seventy
thousand dollars then you get above that
ten times and if that difference is paid
up fully by the state
so if you have a 250 000 cost associated
with a youngster
you're going to be paying locally
part of that but not all that 250 000
part of it
and we have Finance here too and they
could also explain that a little bit
more if we don't get it but this is a
huge issue we did have a bill here
in recent years where we had dropped
that to two and a half times
if you recall that bill and that also it
was a similar concept to this one which
is dropping to one and a half times
so thank you very much representative
Damon
thank you Mr chair
that Mike's giving us a little bit of
problem so we'll at noon time we're
going to have them look at that so we
have one card here that's been similar
oh
Eric
here yes
oh we have another card too yeah come
here let's see what we got coming up
here
I mean we want to
good morning uh House Education
committee thanks for letting me testify
on this important bill my name is Eric
power I'm the president of the school
district governance Association of New
Hampshire
the organization that looks for
responsible governance through budgeting
and educational excellence in our New
Hampshire Public Schools
and I'd like to speak today about this
bill
um just to tell you a little bit about
fcga it has about 50 to 60 members
including 12 state representative
current state representative
Representatives
and we review all legit legislation
involved with education and governance
most of the bills that we review are
through this committee all there are
some other committees as well and we
have our website that provides our
assessment of the bills which you can
review including this one and um so
that's available for reference you'll be
getting an email from me with that
website and I believe you may have
already gotten an email and some
information on an organization excuse me
Eric yes Jen will you please contact
Tech and tell him
yeah
it it might be if if that's taken off
don't don't disconnect don't you see
this is a daisy chain
one element out we lose the whole thing
yeah
can can if Eric talks loudly
hey Anglo is here if Eric talks loudly
can everybody hear him that's what we're
going to do Eric why don't you just
thank you I also served in the military
for 30 years there you go
that retired about 40 years ago so let's
start using maternal voice
um anyway I also served uh being an spga
we have the most all the members are
either current or former school board
members of budget committee members I
myself served on the tallest Brookline
Cooperative school board for three years
and I also have served as a special
education advocate so I have a lot of
background in special education and the
thing that frustrates me both as a
citizen and as a school board member was
that the amount of
this unfunded mandate that comes down
from the state
special education is important it's
needed for students students need this
to succeed in life and there's many
stories about women they do succeed when
they get the special education but it is
a refreshing blow to the taxpayer
especially in small towns but even in
large counties when you look at what
goes into the budget for special
education
it's really not negotiable it's in your
operating budget in a Traditional School
District and it's in your default budget
in an sb2 School District
and so what can be done to help the
towns now there is some heat here and as
a chairman Ladd has mentioned right now
when you get you have to go to three and
a half times the average State
expenditure for students before any Aid
kicks in and at that point it kicks in
at the 80 20 low
um so that the
um the district is responsible for 20
percent
above that three and a half level and
the uh
and then this the state will pick up 80
and then if you get up to 10x the level
which is the current level that's when
the state picks a pole but you're
talking if you get an average number of
is it working yeah article 28a talks
about unfunded mandates and this really
is an unfunded mandate and it still will
be even after this bill but it will be
less of a unfunded mandate so that's why
I think this is important to look at and
to pass to help our school districts
across the state because special
education is something that's been
dictated to us it's something that needs
to be done first for for our special
education students and that population
has grown if you look at recent numbers
it varies but it's anywhere between 15
and 20 percent of our students are
either on an IEP individual education
plan or a 504 plan and so it's not a
small cost and it is really making it
very difficult for our taxpayers
everybody wants to do the right thing
but the state needs to kick in their
their fair share and reducing this level
to three from three and a half percent
to one and a half percent where the 80
20 kicks in is about very much needed
change and it's a bipartisan change I'm
a republican I know it's a Democrat bill
but you know this is the right thing to
do so I hope that this committee
recommends ought to pass you may also
want to consider an executive committee
before this I know there were some of
the proposals some other lsrs that were
put forward that of course Consolidated
there was one to look at that 10x number
that might want to come down to 5x for
example so that may be something the
committee considers because that would
be in the same Spirit to help these tax
the taxpayers especially in these small
towns you look at a town like Croydon
like the previous speaker talked about
they get a 200 000 hit on a 1.7 million
dollar budget that's really substantial
so you really want to look at that and
um I hope that you you do ought to pass
and then also check out
sdganh.org for more on our rationale and
all bills including this one
thank you very much
animation
we also have more students qualify for
this going to one and a half past the
department done any kind of leadership
from Becky of you uh as far as the
youngsters
eligible to receive this program so the
department doesn't have data on those
kids because we wouldn't be able to do
it unless we were able to collect the
financial impacts for those students
however so right now at three and a half
times last year there were 760 kids that
were eligible so the current cap is and
I was just looking at data this is 67
000 and it would drop down to about 30
000 at one and a half times
um now I do want to just remind the
community these are special education
costs alone so
um uh I believe I I missed Becky's
presentation to you all at the
department last week
um but why I don't know if she kind of
walked through the formula but the way
it works is the department collects the
data on these students all of the costs
associated with the students in their
IEPs and reviews all of that detail
there's a cap that's set in law which is
three and a half times right now
um so we find out all of the costs that
exceed that three and a half times and
then we take that amount and we multiply
it by eighty percent which is the amount
the department will reimburse so the
amount over that three and a half times
so any costs over sixty thousand right
now we will reimburse at 80 percent
now in past years and in this year
included
um the Department of Education then will
prorate the payment based on available
appropriation
um so in the past that 80 percent is
sometimes multiplied by 70 percent last
year everybody received 100 of that 80
because we had substance enough
appropriation in the state budget this
year
um we didn't have quite enough or maybe
our total obligation was 34 million and
um our appropriation was say 33 million
making some numbers up there so we
prorated the 80 at 90 something percent
98 so so
um what this would do is a bunch more
kids would be eligible for Aid
um so I think is is there's a confusion
that the existing kids would we would
just be instead of paying everything
above 60 000 we would just start paying
everything above 30 000 that is true for
those kids but this would add additional
kids into the pool that would be
eligible for funding
um so there's two different things so
this bill doesn't come with
appropriation right now so if you were
to just change it to one and a half
times what that would do is the
department would continue on collect
that additional data on those students
calculate what the payment would be for
those students however our payment would
be substantially prorated probably I
don't even know twenty percent I'm just
guessing
um or the legislature could
simultaneously add additional
appropriation to the Department of
education's budget to pay for those
the department has no information that
we can really Target well the only one
the only time we're ever collecting
financial information to a specific
student are for kids that are eligible
for catastrophic State special education
Aid right now it used to be called
catastrophic Aid and I always slept but
State special education Aid um is is for
those kids right now so
um the department begins collecting that
information in the summer of every
single year so the department gets all
the files from the school districts We
compare it to a copy of the student's
IEP to make sure those services are in
the IEP and appropriate
um and then we do the calculation in the
in the fall when we're reviewing all of
those transactions and whatnot so it
would just the file that now includes
760 students might now include several
thousand students
good question
thank you very much Mr chair and thank
you very much Caitlin and Becky and Mark
for joining us on on this
um I recall the the prorated section for
special education Aid because we've
we've talked about it before but where
in the statute is that right now um I
believe it's a 186
something
that sounds right and
um there's a this bill only has a few
Roman numerals on it there's a lot of
Roman numerals in that in that section
yeah I can find you the exact area I'm
just not an expert this is not no no
that's okay because I think that's a
you've raised a significant point on
this and it could also be a budget
footnote so I'm not 100 sure off the top
of my head I'm sure Mark is looking for
you're gonna need more than 22 million
I will say that District districts could
probably tell you to some extent an idea
of how many students would meet that cap
because districts are tracking that for
lots of different reasons at an
individual student level sometimes for
Medicaid reimbursement for Medicaid to
schools sometimes to see if students
will meet the cap for special education
Aid because sometimes you don't know for
sure if a student is going to meet the
cap so there's
um bookkeeping that's done at the local
level to ensure that those IEPs are
being tracked in those services and
things like that are being inputted into
the system because what you don't want
to do at the district level is wait
until June to start inputting your data
for the July 1 collection for special at
a because it's a it's a Time intensive
process because you're accounting for
every student's every sessions service
for the entire School duration of that
IEP so districts could probably give you
an i idea of how many students they
think could potentially reach the cap if
that was something that you wanted
closer to hard data on
okay Rick and a fault Mr chair follow-up
sure on that and the Paul actually
follow-ups too
um before this committee acts on the
okay yeah because I think this goes
beyond I mean this is policy but also
fiscal
yeah it's
I guess it comes down with me that it's
a huge unfunded mandate
and probably the largest one we've got
in education here is
I've heard from many school districts
not just in this state but all over the
country that we're having to borrow from
other areas of our operational budget to
pay for the cost of this type of service
and for the small towns like a Paramount
they see a two Cathy kids in one year a
school district has 67 kids
they just didn't have the money
and so what do you have to do take that
tax anticipation note out or become
trying to deal with essay don't you have
an emergency department some kind of
help us out with that now uh districts
freeze their budgets
districts have to freeze their budgets I
mean that's the reality and even with
the way the current system works this
money is reimbursed to the district so
the district is not getting the money so
that they don't have to find the money
in the moment they're still have to you
know somehow absorb those costs in the
moment and then retroactively ask for
the reimbursement at whatever rate the
department is able to reimburse it based
on what allocation they have set aside
for that so that that this won't change
that process I don't believe based on
the way that it's written now so it
still will have the same impact in that
way
uh thank you thank you both
um I was wondering if either of you
might know uh several years ago we
passed a bill related to
um uh districts forming associations for
the basis of risk pools uh do you know
if any districts have formed such
associations
specific information I can share but I
would imagine Becky Fredette will be
able to provide that information to you
so I'm not aware of any I mean no I
don't think anybody's joined a risk pool
it's
and it's a great idea it came from the
Midwest
didn't it Kansas yeah
I think representative miler
thank you Mr chair uh could you tell us
does a reimbursement take place in other
words
there's a there's a cost that takes
place and they have to pay that when
does the reimbursement actually receive
from the school district on January 1st
of each year sometimes like December
28th the Department's really good but
usually January 1st of each year it has
to be in by the end of July I'm sorry
the input of the data at the district
level they have the month of July to
input the data for the students that
they believe are going to meet the cab
but it's an extensive process on the
department side then to cross-reference
every session that is inputted for each
student for example if you have a
student who gets is in an out of
District placement but also gets
occupational therapy speech and behavior
therapy for example the person who's
responsible for accounting for that at
the district level has to input every
single session of OT every single
session of speech every single session
of behavioral therapy they have to
calculate the rate outside of the
tuition perhaps for that out of District
placement all those things are accounted
for separately for each student in so it
takes a good amount of time so then the
department has to go cross-reference and
make sure the students were there that
day that there's no attendance issues
that what is in the student's IEP
matches what was inputted for the amount
of minutes that you're asking for the
reimbursement for and then calculating
all that to come up with what the total
cost is and then going back to the
district to resolve any errors and
figure out what the errors are and then
that's why it takes till January to get
the reimbursement of the following year
because Victor you need to give us the
cliff notes it's extensive I mean I will
tell you a special ed administrative
assistant at the district level
um this is an enormous part of their job
and for some District level directors
who don't have admin support they're
doing this so take me through this
situation I spoke about Piermont the
kids come in in November yeah two kids
okay tell me how they're going to pay
for this
well do they have a special end I'll
call it trust they don't have any kind
of fun and no fun there
you're going to freeze your budget first
well I'm again I'm not the
superintendent there so I certainly
don't want to speak on behalf of what I
what they would do but in a district
where I've worked in the past the
special ed director or whoever is
responsible for that would meet with the
superintendent and the business
administrator to talk about what is the
current state of their budget what do
they have in operating costs that have
not been expended
um how can they cover the cost if they
freeze the budget completely what costs
can they not take from you know salary
things like that Personnel what other
special ed costs can they not freeze
because you're responsible for paying
for that but that's where
a lot of times that causes this
community Discord
um that I think Mr power was talking
about previously which is that you are
freezing your budget at the district
level to cover these unanticipated
expenses because you're required to do
so and at what cost to the rest of your
school community and it'll cost to the
your entire Community if you don't have
enough money to cover the placements for
example and the district has to work to
try to keep those students in those
placements because that is what the IEP
team has determined is most appropriate
you might have to go back to the voters
and ask for a special meeting and come
up with the money some other way or
you're freezing your budget so all those
things that you have set aside money for
are encumbered money for then that no
longer becomes an option thank you
you're welcome represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair so looking at the way
that this bill operates I have a little
bit of concern that it might actually
wind up hurting some of the people it's
designed to help given the fiscal
constraints around this if we're looking
at modifying the three and a half down
to one and a half we're essentially
spreading a
a moderate amount of money much wider
instead of
a large amount of money more narrowly
focused for those catastrophic cases so
what do you think the funds would look
like around this if say instead of
modifying the three and a half to one
and a half we actually looked at the 20
percent and eliminated that and
reimbursed at a hundred percent over
foreign
it was 100 it would be 100 reimbursement
over that three and a half number it
would be like a 402 placement kind of
situation
oh sorry never mind it would be 10
million dollars
10 million dollars but you're still just
talking about that same core set of kids
sure but you're absolutely right so if
you don't add appropriation to this bill
and you just do it this way you're just
going to further dilute the funding
thank you it's representative luno it's
uh in Roman numeral three
it's the proration is in Roman numeral
three
are there further questions from the
committee here yes yeah um thanks thanks
Mr chair
um and I think to the the point you
raised um Mr chair and representative
Myler with regards to the timing of the
payment I just want to make sure I
understand this so if um if School
District
has a two hundred thousand dollar out of
District placement during the um the
2022-2023 school year that we're in
right now
um when would um when would that
District receive reimbursement uh from
the special education Aid fund under
the following year so I just wanted to
make yeah make sure that was clear thank
you
yes reps and Damon
thank you Mr chair
I'm wondering how often that extensive
presents anything different in the cost
than the school district presented and
then I have a follow-up depending on the
answer so that would be a better
question for Rebecca Fredette so
hopefully she can provide that
information to the committee at a
different time
Mr chair yeah go ahead so I'm just going
to rhetorically ask the follow-up
it seems like it would be possible for
some amount say 50 percent
of the expected reimbursement to be made
available sooner
if there's not often a substantial
difference so the challenge with making
it available sooner is that it's
prorated across the entire state if
there were one District at a time but
and this is true of all you know I think
you'll see other bills that I'm going to
talk about is proration prorating
everybody across everybody else one
District making a substantial so you
might have a district that has one
student with a two hundred thousand
dollar placement that maybe shouldn't
have gone through and now that's going
to throw off everybody in the entire
State once that proration is applied
um and and the um to further complicate
this we do provide estimates to the
Department of Revenue and they're doing
their tax rate setting on October 1st
before the payments are finalized for
their tax rate setting in the fall so
they're using this number so
um one must that if you are throwing
everybody off it just is not great
policy
thank you
yes represent Cornell has her handle her
name represent mileage I I think I'm
confusing myself now
I always thought catastrophic aid while
whatever was it's for placement
residential placements or placements or
no so it's for any child that has costs
above a special education costs above
the cap which is that sixty thousand
dollars so they could all be incurred
locally within their school district but
there are tends to Outer District
assessments tend to have a higher cost
so there tends to be a lot of students
that are out of District placements that
are receiving are eligible for the state
special education
so if we drop it from sixty seven
thousand to thirty thousand I mean
that's pretty easy to reach for
anybody and like if you're in an Autism
program and get a lot of services that's
that's easy
thank you I think it depends quite
honestly I mean
districts already as part of their
beginning of the year data have to take
their staff especially for special
education and divide their staff members
by the number of students that they
serve and figure out what their hourly
rate is and how much each student counts
per hour Etc so districts are already
doing that in data at the beginning of
the year sometimes in District
programming can be more costly than an
out of disreplacement because you are
infusing your General Ed setting with
supports and services so students can
remain in the General Ed setting because
that is what is least restrictive for
that student and that's what the IEP
team thinks is the most appropriate so
that can be as costly it's typically not
necessarily as costly as some out of
District placements but again it's very
variable and it's also about economy of
scale if you are in a very small
district and you have one student with a
very low incidence but High need and
you're creating an industry program for
one student that can be very costly even
if it's the right thing to do whereas if
you're in a district with 10 or 12
students with that same kind of need
it's a lot more cost effective to
develop an in-district program because
you're serving 12 kids instead of one
student or it may be more cost effective
in that small District to send that
student out of District but you can't
make a decision solely based on the
financial
aspects of that placement so it becomes
a little complex
um
I don't know what the effect would be in
terms of number of students from like a
departmental data level but you
certainly could ask districts what how
many kids they think would meet the cap
it would be a little bit of a Time
intensive process but I think they're
already collecting the data if you
helped them figure out what data they
needed to determine that at the local
level I think most people could probably
do that
thank you for their further question
represent Myler thank you this this has
been very instructive thank you but I'm
I think I'm a little confused of one
thing Caitlyn from a standpoint of the
department you have budgeted x amount of
dollars for special ed reimbursements if
if the total for the amounts coming in
from all the school districts
is less
than what you have budgeted
do you then prorate that either up or
down based upon that or if if the amount
is over what you've budgeted explain the
variance of that please so we would only
prorate down we would not prorate up so
if if after we go through that
calculation
um and we figure out that a student is
eligible for 80 of its 80 percent of
their costs reimbursed then we will pay
them 80 percent of those costs we would
never then take that 80 and change it to
85 percent because that 80 percent is in
the statute but if we have only enough
money to pay 75 of that 80 that's when
we prorate that down thank you
thank you are there further questions uh
there's going to be a lot of questions
we have but is there further questions
for
the yes go ahead reverse McDonald thank
you and thank you for the expertise both
of you um to clarify on a point you made
earlier Caitlin
um
would this bill need to add an amendment
or some kind of appropriation for this
communities that already meet the three
and a half times threshold to get the
same amount of Aid if there's going to
be more communities that would meet the
one and a half time threshold
this will reduce the amount of money
available to those existing communities
so are there any other questions we're
going to work on this folks it this
whole thing gets into the area of
weighted categories for the i-13 IEP
categories as well it's all sort of
related you know what's the cost of this
category versus that category and
it's a huge huge problem which we've had
further questions thank you very much
so that does close down the cards which
are are the testimony for this it's 12
o'clock and so we're closing down 577.
thank all coming and talking about that
one today it's let's see it's a big
problem we will pick this up at one
o'clock today for 6 26 right after
foreign
well good afternoon everybody on the
committee here uh and the two members of
the public which are present today
um
we have a bill in front of us HP 626
this is requiring the Department of
Education to administer the education
Freedom account
that's not your bill is it oh that is
your ability it is yeah
um represent luno thank you very much Mr
chair members of the committee
um for the record Dave luno representing
the people of uh Merrimack District 9
which are folks who who live in Beau and
Hopkinton but as um as representative
Miler well knows uh we used to also
represent people in Concord we're not
going to let them go that quickly so um
so here's the people at Concord too but
frankly I like to think that we also
represent people all across the granite
state because all of us have have
statewide responsibilities and while
they may not
see our names on their ballots uh when
we're when we're considering policy like
this or any of the other bills certainly
all the granite Staters are are really
important and relevant to um to our
deliberations so
the bill in front of you of of us uh
this afternoon
is related to the um the education
Freedom account program which was
established in the current state budget
House Bill 2 but it actually stemmed
from House Bill 20 which was heard in
this committee uh
back during the the two days I think we
had a a rock solid two days worth of
hearings on House Bill 20. uh the um the
the blue sheet sign ups which uh are are
basically people uh members of the
public who are signing up
um in support and in opposition to
legislation
for House Bill 20 there were 1107 uh
that signed up in support of the
education Freedom account program and
there were
5218 who signed up against the education
Freedom account program and uh
you know there was there was General I
think displeasure and unease uh
expressed by uh by taxpayers from across
the state who objected to the idea of
using taxpayer dollars to pay for uh
private and Home School uh tuition
choices that um that other families may
may elect to to make and um and
particularly on top of the uh the
already substantial support that local
property taxpayers have for their local
public schools because
um as we all know most of the local
school budgets are are paid for through
uh through local uh property taxes so
so
you know we talked about yesterday how
the education Freedom accounts
um were were billed as as something that
was going to provide great savings to uh
to local property taxes but
unfortunately that has not um developed
at all so so this year
there's a package of bills that uh that
we have that sponsored that looked to
bring some accountability oversight and
transparency to the education Freedom
account program they're not eliminating
the program but they're providing some
some accountability to the taxpayers who
are who are who are you know paying for
these private school tuition bills and
House Bill 626 the one in front of us uh
this afternoon is one of them so the the
title of the bill is requiring the
Department of Education to administer
the education Freedom account uh program
and and you know over the I think this
bill seven pages long that's probably 90
95 plus percent of it so most of it is
replacing the um the uh the scholarship
organization the term scholarship
organization with the Department of
Education or the the State Board of
Education which is the governance of of
the of the uh of of a lot of their their
policies and um
and it really eliminates the um the
Scholarship Foundation from the uh the
administration of um of this of the
education Freedom account program so why
is this important
so
you know all in following these first
two years of of the program where uh New
Hampshire taxpayers are um are into it
by about 30 million dollars not quite 30
million I think it was 27 point
something million dollars currently in
the first two years of the program and
the commissioner of education has
already put in a request for another 60
million dollars uh over the next
biennium to uh to fund education Freedom
accounts so so all in it and uh that's
nine million dollars that the um that
the scholarship organization gets to
retain for their own overhead costs and
um nine million dollars and um going
essentially going to a private
contractor through a no bid uh contract
that was approved by the um the
executive Council uh just about two
years ago and um and so that's why it's
important so so why should and I think
this is a reasonable question on the
part of the taxpayers why should my tax
dollars be going to cover overhead for a
scholar for the for the private
contractor overseeing the program
when we're already paying for Department
of Education that um that that oversees
the education of um of New Hampshire's
kids
um
so so that's that's the first question
that I think this this uh this uh that
house bill 626
um provides the answer other I think is
um is over this last two-year period of
time the only information we've received
from
the um the the private contractor
overseeing the program
uh to a cost to taxpayers of nine
million dollars are basically this these
two pieces of paper and yeah there's
some backup paper to it as well but um
but and and honestly the um the reports
here we talked about reporting this
morning reporting in data collection
the the reporting here is laughable
so you know in one
actually on both of these reports they
talk about the current number of
students who switched from a public
school
to take a education Freedom account to
open an educational Freedom accountant
and attend something other than than a
public school and then they then they
add into that people who did that or
students who did that during the the
pandemic which actually happened prior
to the education Freedom accounts ever
being authorized by the state and then
it even goes on to talk about
pre-covered switchers prior to 2020 and
the number of students who joined
education Freedom accounts so so it's
sort of laughable what um uh what this
what this talks about here and um and
rather than than actually breaking out
the
um the the costs I mean there's some
general categories there's there's lots
of data as to where these students where
they live what districts they come from
lots of data with respect to what it
would have cost taxpayers had all these
students been in their their um their
Public Schools but as we know from from
at least the little bit of you know uh
sketchy information from these reports
at least 75 percent and probably even
more than that of these students were
either already in private school or
going to go to private school or another
or another non-public option anyway
um and and have no cost to taxpayers so
so
how the money is being used
and transparency in terms of reporting
that I think would be fair in order for
the program to be more accountable to
the taxpayers who are now on the hook if
this gets put into the budget for 90
million dollars
of costs in the in the first few years
of of this program so that's the first
part of that's most of this bill the um
the rest of the bill
um is really is really accountability
and it's only on in a few um a few
section A few sections the first is
section six on page one and so this is
down towards the bottom of the page on
lines 24-27 and it's um it's you know
what happens when money's left over in
account and in in the in an edge unused
money left over in education Freedom
account and it basically says that the
money gets rolled back into the the
education trust fund so remember this
it's taxpayer money and then the um then
the the other piece in this bill that I
think is is um related to accountability
and we talk about this in fact we talked
about it this morning
um is uh is how do we know how well our
students are are doing and um and so on
page two towards the middle of the page
lines 22 through 25 uh it eliminates you
know this sort of you know random
nationally standardized Norm referenced
achievement test that doesn't really tie
into anything that you can compare with
how students in New Hampshire are doing
and um and requires
um uh EFA students to essentially take
the same Statewide student assessments
that all of our Public School uh
students take and you know give us
something to to compare to
accountability is important I mean we
heard about it this morning and it
should be important
for people who are Advocates of
Education Freedom accounts and so I
think By Us by by establishing these
guard rails
um will be able to
um to you know improve the program have
a program that's more accountable and um
and uh and transparent to um to the
taxpayer and help be able to have some
real oversight by by the legislature
just like our public school programs uh
have so we hope that members of the
committee will support these reasonable
guard rails again it's a light touch
um uh to protect uh taxpayers and
improve transparency and be happy to
take some questions
thank you very much are there any
questions for representative luno yes
representative McDonald thank you Mr
chair and thank you um we heard from the
Department of Education this morning
that they're already
um strained a little bit because they
have a heavy workload so how is this not
just another thing for the Department to
do and right now another organization is
handling it no thank you very much for
the for the question that's in that's an
excellent question
um you know one way I think of of
looking looking at this is that the the
department could could likely hire a new
employee and I think we saw some numbers
this morning that the first year of a
hire might be around 165 000 uh compared
to the nine million dollars that we're
currently spending
um to uh to manage the EFA program
through an independent contract through
a private contractor so I think using
some of that nine million dollars would
uh to to have a data collection and data
reporting uh specialist and then use
using the the balance of that nine
million dollars which if if the if that
position costs 165 000 would be about uh
8.2 million dollars
and um being able to uh to either use
that for um for efas
so it would actually go to uh go to
students opportunity or use that um you
know as as state funds that we could put
towards any of the other initiatives
that we talked about this morning so so
I think I thank you very much for the
question and and I and I um that's
that's what I would suggest further
questions
yes representative
thank you Mr chairman um thank you uh
when these were first uh proposed I
understood that some of the reason for
using a Scholarship Foundation was to
avoid uh direct money from taxpayers
going to fund religious schools or
religious education and I I understand
you know the Supreme Court ruling is
that they can do that but I'm looking at
religious
um curriculum or things like that is is
there a problem with State money going
directly to these or these organizations
or these businesses which are strictly
religious yeah no thanks thanks for
thanks for the question
um I'm I'm I I've certainly heard
arguments on on both sides of that I
personally believe that that that public
money should not be used for for
religious schools and I believe there is
a provision in our New Hampshire
Constitution to prevent public tax
dollars to be used for
um for religious um uh education I'm not
aware of any U.S Supreme Supreme Court
rulings that would necessarily change
that
that provision
that specific provision but but to say
that the state of New Hampshire and its
time that taxpayers in New Hampshire
should be charged nine million dollars
to an organization to basically
um pretend that that it's no longer
taxpayer money and um and and fund
scholarships I mean I think there are
words for uh for that type of um
um you know uh you know hide and seek of
of of money and um I'll leave it to the
committee members to determine what
those words are but uh but to me that's
not that's not what uh what taxpayers
sign up to when they're um when they're
sending their money to the state
follow-up question
thank you
um
if the money is given to the parents to
do what they wish to do with it then
it's really not hide and seek it is a
decision uh by a different entity that
now has a responsibility over the money
so I'm not sure how that's playing a
game okay
um thanks very much for the for the
question
um if if I'm able to take what you just
said it absolute face value that it's up
to the parent to be able to spend that
money how they like then I'm not sure
why you need an independent or a private
contractor to do that why the parent
can't
um can't be the buffer between the state
and how that that money is being spent
so so I really don't see the necessity
of of having a a a a private contractor
in uh in that role and that's what I
mean by by hide and seek if you're
really that worried about the um the the
the perception of um of what this is
than than having a private contractor uh
in the middle costing taxpayers
um nine million dollars a year producing
these two reports which I don't think
are going to please any anybody
um you know paying paying whose tax
dollars are being used to fund this
program and especially given the uh the
overwhelming opposition to this program
I think you're putting yourself out
there
rather than rather than you know having
something having guard rails in place
that uh that improve and make the
program more accountable to taxpayers
representative Belcher
thank you Mr chair um
you had mentioned bringing in uh the
sort of standardized testing across CFA
programs to to look to see how they're
doing in comparison to our more
traditional Public Schools
but my question is is it reasonable for
us to expect that students who
um perhaps dropped out of high school
and then picked up the EFA program and
are in an alternative program or
students who are in the EFA program
that's focused on either religious
education or a music education to
achieve parity in more traditional
subjects with traditional public school
students no thanks thanks very much for
the question so so there's nothing in
the um in the bill here that would
require students to either be on be
parody Or Be Be have to score above a
certain level on any particular test in
fact the Statewide assessment test is is
already I think a possibility in here
yep that on line 26 on page page two so
if that's not even something new in here
but but I think taxpayers certainly have
a right to question how their how their
dollars are being used and what the
results of of that are they certainly
have a right to do that with Public
Schools they know what that is
um uh you know
for public schools and uh and if their
tax as their tax dollars are being used
to to fund non-public options uh they
should they should be able to know that
and I think the the conditions that that
you laid out representative you know
with respect to um to some types of of
students I think the public I think
members of the public would understand
that
um uh you know as long as some context
was was provided you know along those
ways but to have something that just
doesn't relate back at all I I don't
think that's that's not transparent to
anybody
I have all kinds of questions on these
but we can do them
not in power I mean we can do them in
exact instead of here for the interest
of time so I'm just going to pick one
okay and that's the one you keep
referring to all this money that goes
out
um the up to up to 10 percent
um and
you were one of the ones who wanted all
of this accountability transparency
wanted to make sure that no money was
spent that didn't need to be spent and
the way that that has been accommodated
accomplished is by hiring by the
scholarship organization hiring an
organization to do all of that and that
takes up most of the 10 percent and the
question is if you took it out but you
didn't put it back in anywhere who's
going to do all of the okay every single
vendor
um okaying every single purchase because
every single purchase is okayed as per
request
from people who wanted accountability
that is the accountability every single
purchase is okayed so where is that
going to come you've taken the money out
I don't see it being put back in and
that's a whole company that does that
plus at least four people in the
um and you're saying that one person in
the Department of Education can now do
what all of this is doing I want to know
how you plan on accomplishing that or
are you just going to leave it up to the
parents like it sounded like you just
said
so so um so thanks I mean I I um
you know believe private companies uh do
it all the time I've been involved with
a number of technology companies that
have um you know a purchasing manager
purchasing person that oversees purchase
orders uh for all sorts of different
items uh most school districts have won
um uh administrator business
administrator that uh that that oversees
um
honestly over a two-year period even a
small District might have a greater
budget than the uh than the EFA program
so uh so public school districts do it
all the time they don't
um to my knowledge uh uh spend uh uh you
know you know nine million dollars on uh
on on just a couple people in central
office to uh to track these things so so
the you know leaving up to the parents I
don't think is the right um is the right
answer but I think the department could
could provide a much better solution to
um uh to doing this than um than it what
it appears the um the private contractor
is doing what follow-up
um when we asked this question at the
time this was originally being
introduced
we were told by I think it was Caitlyn
Davis she looked at what it costs
regular public schools and she said it
was more than 10 percent is what they
were spending so my question that's what
regular public schools are spending more
than 10 percent of their budget on doing
this Administration
their use of doing it in less than 10
percent which you've taken out and so I
still want to know and did we heard from
the Department of Education how
overbooked they are now so
who's going to do that who's going to
pay for it where does the money come
from sure so so you know what I'm going
to
where does the money come from money
comes from the taxpayer
um where does it where does it go
currently money that comes from the
taxpayer goes to our goes through the
education trust fund to our public
school districts and those public school
districts have a um have a you know uh a
central office and then the schools that
the central office administers and those
costs are I agree about 10 but what
you're failing to to to recognize here
is that while while
um a significant amount of the EFA
dollars are are not just going to um to
home schools but they're going to um to
private schools and other tuition
programs that also have a um uh an
Administration and management component
that is somewhere between 10 and 15 so
now whether rather than it being
contained in a public school at a total
cost to taxpayers of approximately 10
for administration costs now you've got
10 percent from the the um the private
contractor and another 10 or 15 coming
from the um the uh the tuition uh Pro
the private school and uh so now now
essentially 25 of our taxpayer dollars
are being used for non-educational
overhead and that I mean I from an
efficiency standpoint I'm not quite sure
why that's uh you know appealing to
people in this committee let alone
taxpayers who would like to see um uh uh
efficiency improved and for more of the
money uh certainly certainly more than
75 percent of the money
um of their taxpayer dollars being going
to a student-facing education purpose
sources rather than overhead
representative cordelli thank you Mr
chairman thank you representative
when we first started talking about
education savings accounts
um back a few years ago one of the
criticisms
was based on Arizona which had the first
program in 2011 and the fact that they a
few years later had an audit that found
many problems with the program
um
that was raised as
um a reason why we should not go down
this route
um
there are other examples as to problems
when a government entity has
administered administered such a program
uh for instance Montana Department of
Revenue the Espinoza versus Montana case
where the Department of Revenue
Administration
said we have a blame amendment in our
constitution you cannot send your kids
to religious schools Department of
Revenue Administration made that
determination contrary to the intent of
the law and the decision was made by the
commissioner of that department who
retired a month later
um do you see any danger in a government
entity uh that might change and not be
favorable to continuing such a program
being placed in charge of such a program
so thank you for the question I think
that's a good question
um you know having a program established
in law I think does put a lot of
obligation on the on the government and
and governments are accountable through
their elected officials uh currently
there's nobody accountable in the in the
private contractor to um to uh members
of the public to the voters the way the
way government is um is accountable
that's my first point my second point is
that when asked uh two weeks ago at the
Department of Education when I
specifically asked the commissioner what
information was was reviewed and this is
referring to an interview that he gave
on New Hampshire close up on um uh on
our on WMUR the Sunday proceed eating
and where he said he'd reviewed all the
information and he was confident that
that there'd been no abuse and fraud the
way there has been in other states with
these um with these programs I simply
asked the commissioner what information
did you review and when can we review
that material and the question was
avoided
um uh and and you know what I'm I'm not
at all confident that through the the
the the the law that was um that was uh
put into House Bill 2 put into the
current state budget provides any
information flow from the private
contractor to the Department of
Education let alone anything that's
going to give the commissioner or
anybody else at the department any
satisfaction that there's been no fraud
or abuse in this program should the um
the department of of Education
administer this program they would have
access to that material and be able to
make a solid judgment that could be
reviewed by by by other people and and
by taxpayers as well in a way that that
does not disclose personally identical
identifiable information the same way we
do for public schools and provide those
assurances right now there's no
assurances at all
about what
um in terms of no assurances at all it
seems to me that the legislation does
require an audit on an annual basis by
an independent auditor of the vendor who
is performing the program
um
there are I think um or there is
testimony we heard from the director of
that organization that they provide
quarterly reports
um to the department
um and the department did release
um information in September on their
website about the program
um and um
the
language that's in law now was really
based on a Senate bill
Our House Bill had additional Provisions
in it such as an annual report by the
scholarship organization parent survey
a few other things and there we will
have a bill that does put those things
back into current law to help in terms
of accountability and transparency in
addition to clarifying that there would
be multi there could be multiple
organizations to administer this program
which was unclear in current law and I
have talked to the department and they
will issue an RFP
um uh in the future for
um organizations to come forward
um and that the sole source contract
initially
sent out in 2021 was because the this
children's scholarship organization was
the only one in the state that qualified
based on on law so
I guess my question is
um
I'm not sure where the holes you see in
accountability are
um for for the program with the
requirements we have and the
requirements we will add because in my
mind the best form of accountability is
with parents and they have ultimate
accountability for their children and
they certainly doing this parent in this
program because if they're unhappy with
what's going on they can walk and that's
not always easy in a public school where
they don't have that same ability be it
based on uh districting
so I'm not sure where
um you see the holes in the
accountability and transparency so thank
you I heard that I heard the question in
there thank you very much representative
cordelli um I would just uh you know say
simply by the sheer lack of information
that
um uh that has been released so far by
the Department of Education uh that uh
that it is um impossible to tell from
this that uh that taxpayer money is
being is being spent uh appropriately
it's been absolutely impossible to get
any specific information from the
commissioner to exactly what material he
reviewed and how he came to the
conclusion that he came to and delivered
publicly uh during New Hampshire
close-up two weeks ago and um and having
the Department of Education administer
this at least would put the department
in a position where they have access to
uh to all of that information and
um and and your your absolutely right I
think when it comes to parents being
able to make make parents and families
and students being able to make their
own their own choices but when it comes
to other people's money when it comes to
taxpayers money I don't think that's
where the only choice lies I think
taxpayers have a right to know as well
and to elect public officials that carry
out their wishes in terms of
accountability and oversight and
transparency to make sure that their
precious taxpayer money is being being
used in a way that um that that they
feel meets meets the test
I I've got a question for you
representing oh no
um you you mentioned the beginning you
had two questions you were looking at
and one of those was why should the
state be allocating resources for the
administration or oversight of this
program to the scholarship organization
rather than using our own Department of
Education I think that's basically one
of the questions you asked the question
I ask you in follow-up to that then have
you worked or developed any kind of a
data sheet or worked with trying to get
a hold of information to determine what
costs the department would actually run
into in terms of trying to administer
this program that we're talking about
the EFA program to include all those
resources necessary to do this and can
they do that cheaper than a contracted
service that we presently have with the
scholarship Organization no no thanks
thanks very much for the for the
question and you know I would um I I
haven't I haven't worked specifically
with the Department to figure that out
but my time on a school board has given
me a lot of background and and eyes wide
open to what it actually costs to
administer an educational program to um
to 3200 students which is smaller than
the Concord school district and um and
so so you know I recognize that that
conquered the Concord School District uh
you know doesn't does not have a uh you
know an extensive staff in the central
office to approve purchase orders and
review material expenses and budget
request items and PO requests that come
from the various staff they certainly
work up a budget every year as well and
present it to the uh the Concord school
board for approval and are able to do
that within a um a budget that is is
contained and supported by the the
taxpayers here in Concord so so this is
obviously we're zooming out Statewide
now for for the EFA program but but it's
still a relatively small number of
students by School District size and if
the department of edu I'm sure the
Department of Education could um could
could could uh develop a a staffing plan
relatively quickly to to be able to
perform these these administrative
functions we know that they developed
rules for the the education Freedom
program very very quickly because I
think the the program was approved in
the uh by the biennial budget it that
was signed into law back and it was
probably the end of June 2021 and I
think by September they had they had
rules before the uh before JL Carr so we
know the department can act very quickly
when it comes to the education Freedom
account program I have no reason to
doubt that they wouldn't be able to act
quickly in in this case as well so and
follow up to my question then have you
gotten any information from the
scholarship organization to find out
what their actual costs are you know
we've talked 10 percent of
of it all however what are the actual
costs are they coming in underneath that
and have you gotten any information to
that effect or are they spending more
than that 10 percent
I no I don't have that information
that's a great question Mr chair the I'm
simply working with the legislation that
establishes the program that says the
scholarship organization can can can
keep uh 10 for their their own purposes
in administering the program so uh so
you know uh you know I'm I'm basically
taking a look at uh you know an
organization that that um that was
awarded what what ultimately you know
over these first four years could be a
90 million dollar contract in a no bid
uh uh uh vote on the executive Council
it's a private organization that's got a
current and former State Rep on their
board and uh and you know uh I while
they may be the only game in town uh
currently because I believe they were
administrating the administering the tax
credit scholarship program too
um and I and I don't know how the us of
this program relate to the cost of
administrating administering the tax
credit scholarship program to see if
they're comparable that may be something
that that we could smoke out a little
bit but but again you know this is in
this is in an effort of uh of
transparency and accountability to the
taxpayers because ultimately the uh the
the Department of Education through its
commissioner is accountable to the
taxpayers through uh through the
governor
further questions could I just yesterday
question go ahead
um yes
um law for both the EFA program and tax
credit scholarship is uh 10 for
administration yeah
and we had discussed that when we passed
a bill whether 10 percent well we
chuckled that around a little bit
whether it was too much or not enough so
that I think it might be worthwhile
while going back and looking at some of
that testimony we had representative
Tanner
thank you thank you for taking my
question and thanks to my new law book
uh I'm able to on
21-9 colon 7-a is the freedom accounts
administrator position that we put in
place last year at the end of election
we've actually voted in last year and
that position
um within the division of the education
analytics and resources is a classified
employee at no less than the level of
administrator too and then it goes on to
tell about how it's supposed to oversee
the program
um and uh provide coordinate and provide
technical assistance to uh students
parents in the scholarship organizations
plural
my question is do we know who has that
position uh in the Department of
Education right now or if it is filled
at all and whether
um you know that's part of the 10 that
the scholarship organization gets for
administration
yeah thank you for the uh the question
representative Tanner I um I I sort of
suspect since that was that's in our law
book and that the scholarship
organization doesn't pay for that is
it says that the position is it's
established within the division of
education and analytics and um yeah at
no less than the level of administrator
so that's a state that's a state
employee yeah and um and so so uh so
that's that's uh that's a
taxpayer-funded uh position and
um and I I I I I I don't think but I
certainly don't know that uh that that
that that the the scholarship
organization reimburses the Department
of Education for that position I I don't
have any reason to believe that they
would
um uh you know if that's the you know if
that's one of the questions but but I
also am not aware I'm aware of that
position I'm not aware if that position
spend uh been filled represent cordelli
uh thank you uh yes it's currently uh
not filled they had one hot one round of
um submission of resumes
um and interviews for the position and
ended up hiring none of those candidates
and they have gone out for a second
round and I think that the due date is
this week for a responses to that second
round
thank you question representative Lucas
foreign
thank you thank you
um I'm wondering what all of the
information on the sheets that we got 16
Pages all came from the doe website my
understanding is everything you've been
asking for is on the doe website so talk
about transparency it's all there and
they even have their financial
statements are on the doe website
everything is there so my question is
what is it that you want to know
that's not already up there for you to
see what is not transparent
so thanks very much uh for the for the
question
um when you when you take a look at
we'll try to be specific on this
uh
in the um in the just looking at
spending categories start a program
through June 30th 2022
and uh there's um there's a a dollar
item
computer hardware internet connectivity
and other technological services and
devices for five hundred and four
thousand dollars
um I I I don't know what what these
things are how they're being used who's
using them uh where they were where they
were purchased from uh there's also some
things that I think are more even more
opaque than um uh than that uh and just
sort of going down here
um
textbooks curriculum or other
instructional and supplemental materials
or online instruction required by
curriculum or provider comma school
uniforms and you've got school uniforms
actually in several places that are that
you know or another place that's by
itself so so some of these some of these
spending categories they're they're
clearly I mean there's a lot of textbook
seems to be everywhere tuition seems to
be everywhere
um
various therapies I don't know what
those are I'm probably not the person to
uh to review them but but perhaps you
know somebody that's an education expert
to be able to look at these things look
at some of these purchases as opposed to
the categories that a private contractor
has put them into and say yeah you know
maybe that's not a um a good use of
taxpayer dollars certainly I think the
one of the examples we found in Arizona
was was uh was one of the one of the
um some of the taxpayer money was used
to what by like a jet ski or something
like that I don't know if a jet ski fits
into any of these categories
um or not you know if there's any of
these categories that talk about other
technological services or devices
I just can't tell from this and I'm not
saying that that again that I'm the
expert to be able to to do that but I
think somebody that does have some
governance responsibility uh through uh
through the department
um to the governor would um would would
you know clearly be in be in a chain of
accountability where the uh the current
um organization administering the
program isn't
represent cordelli thank you
um I'm just wondering um based on your
reading of some of those categories are
you looking for information I'm
concerned about privacy
um for the name of someone who is
getting like physical therapy or
something and how much they paid for
that I'm not sure what level
um of information is missing that you're
looking for no I'm not I'm not looking
for that I'm not looking at anything
that I think would be on what a
municipal budget committee would be uh
would be looking for in all that
information is is subject to review by
any of us who um who who requests that
and my experience you know my experience
12 years on the hopping board I think
that's probably eight or nine or ten
years as the board rep to the uh to the
budget committee budget committees
review very detailed expense information
certainly personally identifiable
information is redacted from those
reports
um uh we did have a budget Committee
Member years ago that actually wanted to
to have the names of of people and I
basically shut shut that line of
discussion down so I absolutely agree
with you representative cordelli that
that protection of this sensitive
information uh that's identifiable back
to a student is uh and a family is very
very important and I would not want to
see the department
um
um uh put and you know put any of these
families in uh in a sensitive um uh
situation and uh and I think the
department has gone out of its way to
protect
um uh students and families who are in a
school district where there may be a
small number of students with certain
special needs conditions and um and and
being able to mask out that information
uh uh you know so I I you know I I
wouldn't expect the department would do
any differently with with this data
representative Belcher
thank you Mr chair I'd just like to
rewind for a moment to a point that was
made regarding the that perhaps
administrative cost of this program
could be as high as 25 because they're
essentially doubled between the the
schools and the the program itself but
to get to the bill
we we don't know as of right now what it
would cost in administrative fees to
move this from a scholarship program to
the Department of Education and in
either case I don't see anywhere in this
bill that the administrative costs
associated with private schools are
affected whatsoever could you could you
walk me through how this bill might
offset or lower or prevent that doubling
of administrative costs so so no that's
a good question it certainly wouldn't
reduce the administrative costs
associated with private schools
um should the program should the
administration the program move over to
the department there'd certainly be a a
another level of inefficiency in there
so I'm granting you that I don't think
it would be ten percent of the the
program costs because if um if 10 Over a
four-year period is is nine million nine
million dollars
um that um that you know that's that's a
lot of that's a lot of Staffing and and
I and I don't think it it takes somebody
with too much business experience or too
much school board experience to realize
that that that that that a program that
that that has 3 200 kids in it doesn't
require
that much uh you know Administration to
uh to particularly when you're not
actually administrating the the
development of you know you know your
your
according to these expenses some of them
are buying off-the-shelf curriculum
certainly paying tuition at private
schools you're not administering the
private school they're doing that
themselves they're administering the
payment to the uh to the private school
and that interface with the with the
student
um uh there's just
if yeah there's I I don't think it takes
much to to think that the department
could uh could do that maybe more
efficiently thank you uh representative
are we making some decision share based
upon a sheep that might be a summary or
not certainly it's not the way we would
do our Municipal accounting with the
spreadsheets and the object codes and
all that numbers and all that on it for
certain categories it doesn't look to me
like this has this but what I understood
there was a a program which scholarship
organization had purchased that would do
all that I don't think we're looking at
that program here and so
well hold on well so so this is the
information that's available on the the
department website so I think you might
be referred was there a program called
like digital wallet or something class
wallet
um so I I haven't seen that information
where where where you know actual POS
and and you know uh um you know purchase
order to Amazon for uh you know Windows
laptop or something something like that
you know what we're what we're seeing
here is Amazon is the largest vendor and
we're seeing computer devices being the
third or fourth
um uh biggest cost or you know uh yeah
yeah but you know
um mechanical Pro you know being it's
not broken down by
departments or no it's not or specific
areas like Administration you know
that's right yeah that's right and
that's it may be available Yeah well
yeah but but I haven't seen it available
on anything that's that's been been
pointed in my direction and and
certainly all of our times on school
boards and budget committees we're
familiar with our inch thick annual
reports that we um that we present to to
our our you know the our voters in town
during um uh school district and annual
um annual meetings and the doe 25 that's
laid out in there and the audit report
that's laid out uh in there in the
detailed budget requests that get right
down in the line line by line what are
you requesting an 1100 1200 1300 uh
which are the big the big lines in a in
a school budget and uh and then the
detailed I mean we've had budget
committee members request five inch fix
printouts of of detailed line by line
line
um Rick I mean I don't know what
anybody's going to do going through all
of that but but certainly that would be
something that that uh that a department
would be able that the Department of
Education would be able to use to uh to
audit a program
uh representative yes I have an answer
to those
um the doe does have all of that the
Auditors had all of that it's a huge
spreadsheet it has every single but it
also has the students names all of that
stuff which as you said are a privacy
issues so they couldn't put that out on
the website but the Auditors had all of
that information line by line every
single purchase and exactly what it was
for and the doe has that it's a huge
spreadsheet we the public don't have
that we you know because that includes
all kinds of personal identifying
information and that's why we don't have
it but and it was meant to be easier to
read if we had the categories as opposed
to every single computer because like
you said pages I mean that's an 18 page
report as it is and it would be an inch
thick and we don't each need an inch
thick but that information is there it's
all tracked the Auditors had every penny
spent and the doe has that information I
would be very concerned with a any kind
of an audit or performance audit or they
had student names in it right I wouldn't
accept that I don't think that's an
issue of transparency I think that if
you're going to use like a unique people
identifier or something like that other
than the student's name
um we gotta be very careful yeah yeah
and and and uh
you know along those same lines um Mr
chair I think the department should um
when when getting these reports from the
uh the private contractor
should should make sure that there's no
personally identifiable information in
these reports the same way our school
districts make these reports available
to budget committees with that
information removed my concern right now
and it's not a question that is that we
have a lot of conjecture going on here
right now and we have not seen this
information we're talking about so I I
think we've got to be very very careful
yeah yeah
I agree other questions representative
thank you Mr chair
um for a second drawing the focus back
to page two line 26 which is the
Statewide student assessments and it's a
two-part question how would you address
concerns that this is duplicative of
students attending chartered public
schools that use efas for additional
support maybe an outside tutor who are
already required by as it's writing RSA
190 for a c to take the Statewide exam
and then the second part is
would you address the concern that this
is an additional burden on private
schools who do not ordinarily provide
the Statewide assessment to all students
or home schools as well so no thanks for
the question I think that's a I think
it's a great question I think the to the
first part of that I don't think it
would be duplicative I think you know
you do it for one or the other and it
covers the the requirement in both you
don't have to take the state assessment
twice to the second part private schools
are offered as we've we've heard this
week last week are offered by the
department should they should they wish
to uh where students can take the the
Statewide assessment so so it's not um
it's it's not you know opening the door
to something that doesn't exist already
in in law and um and uh you know they
don't they certainly don't have to do it
for all their students because there's
no law that says says that but for uh
for students who are having their
tuition paid for by public taxpayers I
think there is an accountability
um uh back to the uh the taxpayer and um
and and should a should a family say no
we don't want to we don't want to
um subject our our student to a
Statewide assessment then you know what
they they can they they don't they don't
have to be part of the education Freedom
account program
um obviously you know it only existed up
to two years you know two years ago so
um so you know they could you know
certainly certainly do it without
follow-up yes so again with these
students if they're in a private school
and that school doesn't ordinarily offer
it of course they can that seems to be
an additional burden on that school but
more importantly on the student who
might be singled out from their
classmates saying You must take this
exam well their classmates can continue
with other scheduled curriculum so how
is it so that these students aren't
singled out and that it's not oh this
student's a part of the freedom account
program and the other students shouldn't
know that information like you said
these personal identifiable
characteristics or how is that prevented
if they are required to take this yeah
that's a that's a good question
um I think State assessments were
actually being done online during during
a couple a couple years I think I'd
heard that so there may be ways to uh to
to uh to get that get those performance
indicators in a way that that doesn't
you know it doesn't single out the the
student publicly but I certainly uh I
certainly share your your concern there
but I think there's probably a solution
uh to that that could exist outside of
law specifying I think it's also
important to remember that that you know
that that uh statutes end up becoming a
framework we don't necessarily you know
you know the statute doesn't necessarily
specify every every last little item uh
there is rulemaking Authority on the
part of the um the Department of
Education for under 190 uh what the
statute are we in 194 f
yes uh I believe there's rule making I
know there's rule making Authority Under
194f so so the department would able
would be able to uh promulgate
um you know rules through jail to
address that thank you
we're gonna I'm gonna allow a couple
more questions uh of the presenter we do
have another very important bill that's
right on top of us here coming up
and I'm going to get to that uh go ahead
representative
thank you obviously there's a lot of
um
interpretation of the word accountable
and trans transparency and just want to
do a little education before I ask you
my question in regards to this bill if I
may
um accountability is if you're getting
money and you're going to these
retailers of BJ's and Costco's to buy
snacks for your child
or you're buying ballet slippers for
someone at a ballet school valid very
valid
if that money is coming out of my own
personal budget I'm accountable for that
but when my property taxes are given to
someone to go purchase that when
somebody not on a freedom account has to
buy it out of their own budget
I ask you where is that fair
and to give an example accounting
manuals and I think you mentioned it
compared to the accountability of this
financial report
all public schools have an accounts
payable Clerk
in every expense which includes the
number of that item the vendor who's it
for why is it for why does it need to be
replaced what's the per unit cost and
the total cost
and that those items are put into a
manifest the financial manifest given to
all the public school boards to approve
every individual expense and vendor
before you can spend that money
and a school board member
can say
nope we're not buying
um something for the music department no
we're not buying it so you have to pull
that and you're not buying it that's
public transparency because your board
members are elected officials elected to
represent your whole community and so
there's a difference in transparency
there and I think that's what your bill
is focusing on is to make sure I mean
this final financial report is horrible
it has no number of textbooks what kind
are they who are they for same for
anything else on that list and then the
the accountability fact sheet doesn't
even have the same information on year
one as it does on year two
um and I'm getting to my question though
if the department of Ed were to overtake
this project it already sounds from what
representative cordelli says there'll be
a staff person so that shouldn't be an
issue but I want to know all of these
reports and I have about 22 of them that
a public school is accountable for for
transparency which includes school
safety asbestos management Emergency
Management plans air quality assessment
assessments student assessment student
progress student growth
I have at least 22. how about the doe 25
which is extremely thorough
and time consuming yeah I know you're
like they need to redo that one too
right but that is transparency that
tells every taxpayer in my neighborhood
on what the dollar that was collected
from their pocket is being spent on
whether they like it or not that's why
you have public meetings so I think
there's a little education that needs to
be done it's not pro how you're
educating Kids versus they all got to go
to public because I I don't believe that
but when my property tax dollars are
going to
personal choice questions and it doesn't
get reported out that's the sin so my
question is sorry is if if this pass so
that the department person that we're
hiring for
efas would they be accountable for all
the same reporting public reportings
that are in I platform all of those data
reports I mean would you expect that to
occur so that there would be
transparency and I think that would
truly strengthen what people are trying
to do yeah no thank thank you very much
Dr cascadden and and I think your
explanation of how transparency and
accountability go hand in hand is
important because it's hard to have
accountability if you don't have
transparency in place where taxpayers
can see how their money is being spent
and then can can make a decision in the
voting booth as Oppo you know in terms
of who they want representing them
making these policy decisions
um and and the the oversight element as
well is very important and
representative cordelli laid out how uh
how there is there there was a bill that
um that uh that passed uh uh last year
that I think representative fellows had
had introduced that that actually does
have a uh have an oversight audit
legislative oversight audit of the um uh
of the education Freedom account program
it doesn't begin I think until 2024 2025
it it so so
um uh so we haven't we haven't seen that
yet but it's hard to have oversight when
you don't have transparency when you
don't have the data there to um uh to to
look at and um and
let me make sure I get the the rest of
what you what you asked about Korean
College of state reports
provide the ms-25 to the Dr right
yeah so I'm not again I'm not I'm not
that this bill this bill is not the bill
that that that requires all of that
reporting uh in there but um but it
would be a start to have the department
be able to collect and and and collect
that information review that information
make that information
um uh transparent to taxpayers in a way
that protects
um uh student and family identity just
the same way school districts do when
presenting that information to budget
committees and presenting that
information to voters uh and um
uh and it it it it really moves I think
the the program in the right direction
to uh to not have a level of of worry
and and suspicion because we just don't
know how um how money is being spent
thank you very much
we're gonna have to we have some other
folks waiting that are coming on the
next bill which is Medicaid Direct
no we're closing this down we're going
on to the next if the questions don't
come from us they go to him and and and
we're done with this presenter well
you're not done with me uh well you you
know I know I gotta live with you the
rest of the year
um actually at least the rest of the
afternoon yeah exactly so can you try to
close it up though because we are I'm
I'm done okay that's what I'm saying
yeah yeah
okay yeah yeah no no it's all you guys
thank you very much we don't have any
other pink cards on this one right now
other than the prime here so we're going
to close this hearing it's done actually
I'm not even sure you got one from me
no I never do get but I will I will no
you do it just they come in later
they're always happy with that
I'll give you three after we're done try
going across the border without your
passport
okay I got a card
okay yeah
otherwise no you could stand down no I'm
I'm I'm introducing the next one oh
you're going to do that for Mary for
Mary yeah yeah she she talked with you
yesterday about exactly okay good
oh that's what you're referencing that's
what I said you're not done with me
that's that's good okay uh we're going
ahead now with hb601 that's this is a
bill relative State participation in the
Medicaid direct certification program
for free and reduce price School meals
so with that uh the prime sponsor Mary
Heath is not available at this point in
time so represent Luna is going to
present the bill so great thank you very
much Mr chair members of the committee
for the record Dave luno representing
Merrimack County District 9 the people
who live in Beau and Hopkinton uh and
like I said all across the granite state
um but um uh thank you for um uh letting
allowing me to introduce House Bill 601
in lieu of the Prime sponsor the
representative from Manchester and I'm
delighted to um uh to to have the
opportunity to do this uh the chair
chair lad and I were involved in a um
an ad hoc committee last year year
before last year on on specifically this
uh this item and and uh
um and and it's important for um uh for
this committee it's important for uh for
people all across uh the state and
I'll briefly tell you why and then and
then I think turn it over too well we
have several other people here we have
the Health and Human Services here in
the Manchester school boards here also
okay and I and I also um I I I believe
uh Mark manginello is going to also be
here for technical advice but uh but we
may be I think we're probably covered we
also have this bill set up for our work
session in the following and that may be
that may be the yeah yeah here we go so
perfect so
um so House Bill 601 is actually it it
it it sounds relatively
um you know you know benign in terms of
uh in terms of what it's asking to to do
but it has very important
um um manifestations uh in a couple of
different areas that are important to um
to taxpayers families and students all
across the state
um the um
the title of the bill is uh relative to
participation in the Medicaid direct
certification program for free and
produced uh free and reduced price
School meals so the 300 free and reduced
price lunch program or School Meal
program is uh I think um we all know
part of the national school lunch
program administered by the uh United
States Department of Agriculture and it
basically and and
Mr manchinello can can probably explain
the the mechanics behind this uh it
basically provides federal funds to um
you know through the Department of
Education to school districts who make
meals available on a free and reduced
price basis to uh to students so prior
to um prior to the pandemic and uh and
represent lad I'd really appreciate you
jumping in it with the numbers because I
meant to fill in a couple blanks and I
just never got a chance to but prior to
the pandemic I think we had about 48 000
000 48 000 students in the free and
reduced price lunch program Mark will be
able to give us that almost exactly so
and it but it was it was something
something in that range
um and um uh but but even that number
doesn't actually reflect the number of
students across the state who would be
eligible at 185 percent of the federal
poverty level who would be eligible for
to participate in the free and reduce
light price lunch program so it's
already an underrepresented number and
um and um
you know and and I think we've probably
all heard you know anecdotal references
from school building principles
um
um the chair has has mentioned it a
couple times based on his experience in
in public education that that sometimes
it's like pulling teeth to get uh to get
a student to return a free and reduced
price lunch
um uh application to be able to
participate in the program
um and uh and yeah there can be a number
of different reasons behind that either
the paperwork doesn't get delivered home
or they never got the paperwork to begin
with or they didn't feel like writing
down all the thing or they just wanted
to be private and not not go into it but
anyway the number the number really
doesn't doesn't reflect the um the
actual eligibility uh
from these low-income households across
the the state and um and uh you know
but since the pandemic and and this is
where I think it really has has has
impacted uh students and and primarily
students for now
um the um the number of the the well
during the pandemic the Department of
Agriculture issued waivers to local
school districts so that they didn't
have to collect free and reduced price
lunch application forms for students
everybody be eligible so uh so uh so
kids I think in most schools got free
lunches
um uh during the during the pandemic and
um and didn't have to submit any any
paperwork and uh and now so they we've
got that inertia built into the system
where where paperwork just isn't being
returned to do this and I think now
looking at the um the doe numbers and
maybe 35 five thousand students or
something right around there so you know
off by you know off by almost you know
twenty percent or so uh from from where
we were pre-pandemic and so what does
that mean well for families it means
that that
they need to they you know some families
are going to need to be spending you
know 25 or 30 dollars a week maybe forty
or fifty dollars a week on breakfast and
lunch programs where they'd be eligible
instead for free
um a free meal and uh and these are
these are low income families to um to
begin with and um
maybe these kids are going without
um
you know without lunch without breakfast
I you know I don't know
um but uh but in any case they're not
they're not getting the um the access to
the federal fund through the federal
funds program to uh to support their um
their their meals during the uh during
the school day
um and um and and I you know another you
know it's hard to get this information
out to families but today uh today I
think schools are very much up to speed
with electronic point of sale uh systems
so that it's not kids reaching into
their pocket for a five dollar bill and
giving it to the lunch lunch person and
them ringing it up and then the next kid
in line oh that's okay Dave you're
you're free and reduced you can you know
just go right through no reaching into
the pocket you know for cash they're
cashless they're using their student ID
to uh to swipe through
um in some cases debits at five bucks in
other cases it just goes right through
and um uh because they're a member of
the program so so I think you know we
were talking about student privacy
earlier that's important I think school
districts have really upgraded their
systems to um uh to do that
um
so House Bill 601
um by by by passing this would allow the
uh would actually direct the Department
of Education to participate in a program
that's now a pilot program being offered
by the department I think it's the
Department of Agriculture to uh to use
um or maybe dhh in conjunction with DHHS
right you're right yeah SDA yeah
um to um to use Medicaid data
to qualify students for free and reduced
price lunch and it can be done
automatically and um in fact it can be
just done automatically no paperwork
required
um no no hassle on the part of the
student on the family it happens privacy
is protected this is data that the state
has already already has
uh and um and we'd be able to use it
because 601 would would direct the
department to work with um with with our
other
um uh Health and Human Services in New
Hampshire to be able to um to rely on to
use this data uh to um identify the
students who qualify for free surprise
lunch it's good for families good for
kids
good for student outcomes you know we
heard the connection that you know when
kids are fueled up they they do better
in class too so um so but uh but there's
another important factor too
a significant amount of the state's
adequacy Grant is tied to the number of
free and reduced price lunch students a
district has and it's significant
um it's um
Mark can tell you the number I just
don't have it off the top let me explain
how FY 19 we have to back off to FY 19
to figure out because of that period of
time where we work and how that
identifies poverty and all the
association figures so so so the state
of New Hampshire used in its adequacy
formula so now we're at 198.40a
um 198 colon 40a and um and it uses
pre-introduced price launch in the
adequacy formula as a proxy for um um
for students who come from for the
number of students that come from
low-income families it's not perfect
it's not great but it's the best we we
had uh until now in uh in New Hampshire
and um and there's there's strong data
that suggests and the state of New
Hampshire has embraced this connection
for decades now that um that that it
caught cost more to edu for district to
educate all their students when there's
a higher number of students that come
from low-income families than in a
district where there's very few students
then come from low-income families so
it's not a personal thing like it costs
more to educate Dave luno because he
comes from a low-income family you know
than it does Mel Miller because he
doesn't it's not that it's it's a it's a
whole district-wide cost so when the
when the when the when the free and
reduced price lunch student count Falls
so does the state adequacy Grant to uh
to school districts used that the school
districts use to educate all their kids
doesn't mean their budget's any lower it
doesn't mean their costs are less but it
does mean that that they get less money
from the state and we know when you get
less money from the state you get more
money from the local property taxpayers
and um
you know and that's something that's
that's particularly hard on uh on you
know so many cities and towns um all
across New Hampshire so so bottom line
is and I'll hand it over to the
technical experts is that uh 601 allows
us to automate the process be better
reflective of the um of the the students
and where they go to school
who qualify for free who are basically
qualified for free and reduced price
lunch and um and
make sure that those students are
getting the the federal benefit that
that they need saving their families uh
thousands and thousands I mean thousands
of dollars a year you know across the
state and number two making sure
districts are getting the resources that
that they're owed from the uh from the
state of New Hampshire based on the uh
the the low income
um you know concentration that that they
face obviously it varies widely places
like now I almost pointing over
representative Cornell so Manchester has
a has I think one of the highest
low-income uh uh you know low economic
populations in the state but it's all
over the state they certainly have the
highest number but but North Country all
across the state there's places that
don't but that's why we've got a dynamic
school funding formula that takes into
account that this will help to automate
that process be fair for families and
taxpayers thank you very much
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
so I just want to clarify and make sure
I'm understanding this correctly
um and just for background because I
know the terms confuse a lot of people
so Medicaid
is children and pregnant women and some
disability folks with disabilities
versus Medicare is for people over 65.
so if I understand this correctly what
would happen is folks who are already
certified in Medicaid the children
that information would be communicated
from health and services Human Services
to Doe
to mitigate the need to do free and
reduced price application is that
correct I I I believe that's correct but
I think that's a great technical
question to uh to the folks who are
going to come up I'll revisit it thank
you
further questions from the committee yes
represent Woodcock
uh thank you for bringing this topic
forward for representative and the
others and I say it's clearly extremely
bipartisan uh bill I should I should I
should note that this language was
originally put forth by representative
umberger okay good one okay
um that being said the uh question I
have is this would this bill negate the
current process that she was from uh
students that's currently do paper and
and applications or they just supplement
it I believe it would it would negate
that that process so that you would not
have principles chasing down
so they're met go ahead okay so you saw
the your thinking is on the by doing it
this way it's going to be expanding the
the eligibility not the eligibility pool
but expanding the pool let those folks
know they're eligible and participate
correct you'll you'll you'll be much
much closer to the the full eligibility
number than the paperwork current
paperwork approach is getting us thank
you thank you Mr thank you yes
representative Parnell
and this might be a technical question
too but does every kid who gets free
reduce lunch are they always on Medicaid
already
I don't know the answer to that no I
no and I think that's I you know I think
that's a good technical question I think
that it's also important to note that
this isn't a okay we've hit the switch
and we go from paperwork to to this this
is a pilot program there's a lot of data
that needs to be shared analysis that
needs to be done and um and and then
implementation of it so this isn't a um
you know hit the switch let's start it
right now type of thing but um uh but I
think all of that will uh we'll be able
to come out
in the technical any further questions
representative cordelli um thank you
um
you mentioned in terms of the current
application process
um there's a whole host of reasons why
family might not return
um an application one of them was
because they wanted to be private and
don't want to do it
what about those families what about
those parents who might not want to
participate in this program but now are
automatically enrolled in the program
without any chance to decline
participation yeah thanks so so the this
isn't really defining this is defining
going into the pilot program I think
that's an important point that that if a
family or a student well a family wanted
to opt out they certainly could I don't
think you can force any student to
necessarily eat a meal that's put in
front of them you know by the school
district they could always bring a bag
lunch they could you know seniors in
some districts have open campus so I I
don't think it prevents them from from
uh from seeking other options but it
just simplifies the process
uh thank you
um but still
um that family's information
is being transferred without their
knowledge and without their consent
um so the the opt-out might apply to a
kid eating lunch but it doesn't
um apply to an opt-out for their
personal information
um I I hear what you're saying I I I I
think it would be you know if the state
decides to move forward with a pilot and
then move forward with an implementation
that it could consider what other states
are doing
um you know in this vein a lot of other
states
Pro probably people who have been
principals in in in States outside of
New Hampshire
um might might be able to talk about how
it might be done differently in in other
states using a similar process to this
maybe not with Medicaid data but with
other data uh uh but uh but I I
absolutely hear what you're saying
representative cordelli and I'm I'm sure
that um that that a um you know that uh
uh uh policy could be put in place that
protects the privacy of these students
and Families
representative Tanner
um Medicaid isn't
uh it's an opt-in program in itself
isn't it
uh it it
I'm not I'm not a Medicaid expert but I
I I think you have to yes you're right
right
um
we do have HHS here yeah which can help
us on that one yes yes represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair
is there any concern here that
um adopting yet another Federal program
puts the state in a position where we're
crafting more of our rules around
Federal programs that could be changed
at any time by the federal government
so so thanks for asking the question
Medicaid's not a federal program it's a
state uh run program with a federal
match to it and but the state defines
the terms of Medicaid we'll be seeing
some more of that and I think Medicaid
specific legislation coming over from
the Senate uh but uh but this is this is
like I said simply to make it easier on
students and families I think there may
be some some uh conditions such as what
representative cordelli has pointed out
that uh that that would need to be
addressed as a as a program gets uh gets
defined but I think we're at the
earliest of the early stages of just
trying to understand what what the
program could look the other concern is
we may be leaving money on the table
uh with uh we have a lot of federal
programs for example Carl Perkins is one
which the Carl Perkins Grant is also
based on poverty that's part of the in
that equation
so if we do leave money on the table
we're losing out in that thorough
dollars and it means that we end up as a
state having to cough it up
and you know here we are we're going to
have our local taxpayer pay it great uh
so it's something that we need to look
into here and we need more information
on it I think that's right that's
exactly what this is yes reps and
Records
thank you and thank you for looking into
this I did last year read the
application form and it didn't give us
an option of applying and checking it
out it basically said if we apply we are
promising to follow through all of it
and to become part of the program if
we're accepted etc etc I wasn't sure if
you were aware of that but given that
I'm wondering if this is a big if
Medicaid is Statewide and is state
um overseen why we need to do why we are
pursuing this Federal program that has
us turn in all kinds of different
information and make commitments to
follow through and all of that why are
we not just looking at our State
Medicaid numbers ourselves I thank you
very much for the question and I think
that would be a good technical question
for the for the people coming up folks
we had we were talking about 50 000 at
one point in time I think we're up 90
something right now 94 000 or so that's
what I heard from Bia the other day and
I don't know where they're getting their
information but uh something for us to
any other questions we we do have other
people on this one right here
thank you very much thank you
hey Robert Berry from HHS hey Robert do
you want to speak now or do you are you
wanting to either way it's probably
better if I defer I'm not here to talk
about the nuances I'm here more to talk
about the relationship between the
Department of Health Human Services okay
that's I'm very narrow in scope so good
what what we'll do is I'll hold you
often okay thank you uh the next person
representative Ladd and members of the
committee thank you so much for uh
allowing me to talk today I just I'll
make a couple of points because I'm
giving you a bunch of paper
um I um
so Medicaid direct certification is as a
representative I'll try to be brief
because he covered a lot of my points so
I'll just um I'll just say that um
Medicaid director reduces child hunger
and reduces the administrative burden on
schools
at New Hampshire hunger Solutions we
feel that improves uh and and many other
folks believe that it improves student
access to healthy meals and reduces food
insecurity with important positive
outcomes for Children's Health learning
and behavior
um it increases efficiency by reducing
administrative burden
reduces School Meal enrollment errors
and we're accurately measures children
living in poverty I just wanted to note
that USDA has been running the pilot
since 2012 and 39 other states have
participated
so this is not you know a new uh idea
and Most states who participate found
that it lowered administrative costs to
schools
increased accuracy of of the data
and of course increased student access
um
the the Departments will will tell you
that that they've been doing direct
certification for other programs for the
last 16 years for SNAP for TANF
um and uh and a number of other programs
um and they know how to do it to protect
privacy
um and just to be clear nobody makes
children uh eat meals there's uh that if
a family sends a meal to their child
they do not have to participate even if
they're certified it is not a um it is
not a reach out and force this child to
eat a meal that never happens
um so the the opt-out is to send your
child to the meal to school
um
it's I just wanted to note that this the
staff from schools can tell you with
more eloquence than I but um the staff
and paperwork that are currently
required to manage the free and reduced
meal program collecting those forms is
not insignificant and this really
streams line the streamlines the process
in a way that allows School Food Service
directors to focus on feeding children
um and and you know creating the best
nutritional program that they can
um so
um and I'll just uh close by saying
hunger levels in New Hampshire are high
right now unless census household pulse
survey 177 503 households with children
reported having insufficient food and
that's an increase of over 30 000 since
this August with a food insecurity rates
climbing School meals are even more
essential to Children's well-being than
ever and I urge you to support this Bill
thank you very much are there any
questions yes representative
yes thank you for taking my question
I'm
trying to understand this whole program
and how it all fits together with the
other programs
um
and as you mentioned we already direct
certify with TANF and you know some of
the others and my question is if we do
this
um Medicaid direct certification with
the federal government who also supplies
the money or some of the money for the
free and reduced lunch
and
if we do that can we still
do other methods like if we turn in you
know X number of students and that's
greater than the number that we get from
Medicaid because maybe they're not on
Medicaid but they're they are in one of
these other programs can we still do
that or will they only then take
the people in this direct and we can no
thank you for the question
representative I I just want to be sure
I understand so is the question that
you're asking
um if we do Medicaid direct
certification could other children be
included for free and reduced meals is
that right like we do now with TANF if
there's somebody who is or one of those
other programs uses that but doesn't
uh hasn't applied for and doesn't take
Medicaid
will of the federal government still
honor that money for the TANF student or
whatever
if we're doing the Medicaid direct or
will they only pay us for the Medicaid
Direct
students no Medicaid uh sorry
so Medicaid direct certification is just
the process of sharing the data across
the agencies the free and reduced meal
program has its own eligibility which
doesn't which this doesn't change
children are at free at 130 percent of
poverty and um and reduced at 185
percent of poverty and children who are
not on the Medicaid Program who meet
those qualifications could apply for
free and reduced meals and federal
dollars pay a hundred percent of the
meal part
they would still do that yes sure
further questions from the committee yes
representative very similar on the
coattails of Representative of Lucas
um snap antenna TANF we usually just
whoever does the director in the
district gets only a case number from
the family
so would that Medicaid would be a third
program as an option for
bring reduced so that maybe a case
number would just be added
or
to Medicaid recipients do they also
receive snap and TANF so that it would
just be the Medicaid number that the
school would get to certify
so thank you for trying to see if
there's a difference because I think no
matter what I suspect we're going to
need online applications or paper
applications so you don't miss kids who
don't qualify for these social programs
oh well thank you for the question and
in terms of what exactly the data
matching looks like I can't actually
answer that question but I bet some of
my uh fellow
testifiers in the room can
um
I will say that um the programs that are
directly certified include
snap TANF uh kids were homeless kids
were in foster care system
um and
um a head start and I'm and I'm sure
I'll be corrected by someone else if
I've missed something but but I think
that adding Medicaid would be a similar
process
um
further questions from Nick Betty
now see thank you very much thank you
um
oh
hi hi
welcome welcome I'm just so honored to
be in front of all of you I am I took
the liberty of reading all your
biographies online before I came here
today
and I am absolutely Blown Away by oof
congratulations as being the youngest
rep and the second youngest in the
country thank you congratulations on
your yellow lab there's so many things I
I read all the great things about you if
you want to know like what I found
particularly appealing and I believe
Keane stayed over here correct I also
made that bad mistake of going there as
well for my undergrad but there's
there's so many great opportunities but
what I'm here to do is is obviously I am
in support of this bill
um I was a teacher at Milford High for
25 years and I know um many of you had
already talked about different stories
and and I again as with all your
biographies you've all had an attachment
to education in your case from Alaska to
Maine and I know you've gone so you've
seen it all
um but my point is as a teacher my room
was actually right outside the cafeteria
when you opened up my door you stepped
into the cafeteria at Milford High
School so my students never had a reason
to be late from lunch or even they were
always the first ones in line at lunch
which is even better
um but in that capacity I also was able
to have
um the milks that were left out in the
cafeteria or the orange juice as left
out I was the one that could gather them
all up and bring them in to put them
into my classroom refrigerator and
because I had C block off which was our
Lunch Period
um you know my door was always open
because quite often kids need sometimes
another place to go other than the
cafeteria so my room was very
accommodating we always had music we
always had but I but more importantly I
always had snacks and um that was an
incredibly important I could go down a
Litany of students Litany of students
and many of you probably could too about
how important food was for their
educational process so well-fed kid you
know mileage the the mileage you get
um I'll ask actually use myself as my
example though
um when I was in seventh grade my dad
thinking that it was going to be a good
idea to separate my brother and I and
give us each a separate room split our
room in half and I got one half he got
the other
um unfortunately my brother got the half
with the heat induct in it I did not
um which was supposed to get fixed for
the next 12 years but never did I could
actually scrape ice off the window in my
room my girlfriend in 10th Grade gave me
a space blanket that was supposed to
warm me up like the astronauts I don't
know if that worked or not but um
when I I went to Bishop Garden High
School
um basically on scholarship
um and I was amazed that my life was a
lot different than others I went to my
friend's house Harold's whose father was
a dentist when I walked in his front
door
um he had a water fountain in the middle
of of their their entrance the only
thing that was wet in my house was the
smell of wet dog on our carpet and on
our couches so I knew things were
different
um and I knew you know something was up
my mother had grad had gone to eighth
grade dropped out and became a
hairdresser my dad was kind of a
deadbeat so we were kind of on our own
and um I didn't have the same luxuries
as they did and I was an average kid but
I always was going to school hungry uh
BG didn't have a free you know free
reduced lunch it was a private school so
we didn't get any of that so it was
really interesting how you could go
through school and learn how to starve
um but what a shock when I went to Keene
State and they actually had a dining
Commons and that I gave my Freshman 15
in two weeks I was it was amazing but
more importantly I'm just a story I want
to say is that I was going to get milk
one of the days and at Keene State you
had chocolate milk you know whole milk
and two percent milk so I filled up my
chocolate milk with um half a glass and
I went over to the whole milk and I
started to pour whole milk in it and one
of my friends was like what are you
doing and I said well you know you have
to you have to cut the chocolate milk
because it's too rich it's too thick you
can't drink it on its own and he's
looking at me and he's like are you nuts
and I'm like well no that's what my
mother always did you know I mean that's
what we did and he sat there and he said
you know you should try it just by
itself and see how that works out you
know and my wife also went to Revere
college and she had the same system
there too
um and I just I was blown away that you
know my mother kept that a secret and
and that's the way it was and so living
through that type of poverty and and
just to backtrack a little bit when I
was a girl and there was a brother child
else that I had who who figured it out
like whether because I wore the same
clothes all the time or the same time
all the time he kind of figured it out
that I needed something and I needed you
know so he always had a little cabinet
and many of you teach us know this we
always have our own little cabinet mine
was a lower bottom right drawer where we
had snack Central
um and everybody who says teachers pay
you know but we also pay most of our
money not for school supplies but for
snacks as well
um you know he always hooked me up with
a snack and it was very very important
because I would actually he even gave me
the he said look just come here in the
morning Nobody's around grab a snack I
used to drink Welch's grape juice which
I never even you know I didn't like
grape juice but I drank it because that
was there
um and he also had crackers and stuff
stuff too and Little Debbie snacks
when I became a teacher I realized how
important that was and I carried on that
same tradition and again like my room
was right next to the calf and you could
always make sure
um that kids could have a snack and the
same thing my room was open every
morning for lunch and so on like that
I really believe that we're one bite
away quite often or one meal away from
turning a kid I was an average kid I
could have gone either way it would have
been really really easy for me to take a
bad Road you know and to have somebody
invest in me change the entire Outlook
of my life I I just retired from Milford
High School in my 25-year tenure I was
nationally recognized twice as teacher
of the year I was four time New
Hampshire teacher of the year I was a
James Madison fellow recipient in 2000 I
was the president of the New Hampshire
Council for social studies
I believe that none of that would have
happened if I didn't have the right
direction do you know what I mean and I
think you know lots of times we sit
there as Educators and say where are the
you know we're the Thomas Jefferson's
where the George Washington's where the
James Madison's and they're in the
classroom you just got to kind of give
them a chance you know what I mean and
if you don't cultivate that they could
be anybody they could be that kid that's
starving you know and you give them a
little a bit of nutrition like well
you're a constitutionalist like
Jefferson says the tree of Liberty needs
to be watered right you water a child
once in a while and there you go you
know and the next thing you know you
have a producing adult
um sadly just as an end note I went to
go thank brother Charles um he was uh
kind of put to pasture when they retire
down in Rhode Island for BG and I took
my 12 year old daughter down to the era
when I won my first national teacher of
the year just to let him know oh my God
and
you know and I went down there
um he was suffering from Alzheimer's so
he never got the chance to know just how
important he was to me
so don't take that away from anybody
else and I'm all better now I can
compose myself I'm good but uh so that's
just a quick story like we all have
stories but I just thought that
sometimes you know my story was was just
as important as the number in 25 years
of kids that came in and out of my door
I know I went over a little more than
five minutes I'm sorry but thank you Mr
chair and
um thank you for letting me address you
Allen and congratulations you all have
so many amazing accolades to your to
your resumes and stuff I'm just so nine
children
I'm just so honored to be part of this
body today so thank you very much well
you may know too much here huh no no
thanks very much are there any questions
representative miler
I want to thank you for your service
and the number of students that you have
touched in your professional career
you have made a difference in their
lives thank you very much thank you very
much sir and the essay you've made a
difference too because of all the things
you did for the Nea so
Dave Before You Escape uh this is your
address and phone number because we are
looking at on the oversight committee
social studies you said you are
president of the New Hampshire Social
Studies not now but counts but at one
point in time yes as Jefferson says you
know with little civic duty every now
and then happier knowledge if you don't
mind if we can give you a call somewhere
along the way and talk to you a little
bit about social studies sorry to be
honored thank you very much very much
thank you all
thank you let me get that down
thank you Mr chair and the members of
the committee nice to see you again my
name is Sean Parr I'm on the Manchester
School Board where I sit on the policy
committee and then and chair the
education legislation committee today
I'm speaking on behalf of the Manchester
School Board which has authorized me to
Advocate that Medicaid be used as a
primary calculator for free and reduced
meals numbers for New Hampshire school
districts we are unanimous in our
support of New Hampshire's application
for the Medicaid direct certification
program as proposed in hb601 the current
process for School Meal applications is
cumbersome and undercounts the number of
students actually eligible for free and
reduced School meals Medicaid direct
certification would reduce
administrative costs related to these
applications while also increasing
funding vital to feeding our students
this is a nonpartisan issue that
benefits all our students in fact many
states as you heard already participate
from California New York Pennsylvania to
Kentucky West Virginia and Alabama
evidence from States who participate in
Medicaid direct certification
demonstrate its Effectiveness it
improves low-income students access to
nutritious meals while decreasing State
administrative costs like these states
New Hampshire would benefit greatly from
adopting Medicaid direct certification
and we ask that you support this Bill
thank you for your consideration thank
you are there any questions from the
committee
thank you very much
um is it Alex Grappone yeah
yeah okay
hi thank you for having me
um as I already said I'm Alexander
Grappone from Concord High School I'm
currently a senior and I'm the president
of our high school save the children
club which deals with tackling the issue
of childhood hunger
um when you go to school you want to be
successful right because the whole goal
is getting into college and going places
and doing things but you can't do that
if you're hungry if you're hungry you
lose focus if you're hungry you can get
more upset to a small minor glitch in
your day and if you're hungry you just
you honestly can't Thrive the way you
could if you were running at maximum
capacity of being able to have access to
food there's a population of students
that come from foreign countries and
their parents don't speak English so how
can you expect when you give them a form
in English for Medicaid for free and
reduced lunch that they would know how
to fill it out with not being able to
fill out those forms those students go
hungry and when they're hungry they
can't learn and when you can't learn you
can't be the best student that you can
be and this starts from day one they go
to school a lot of these kids come over
here at the age of seven so from the age
of seven they're not eating and they're
not focusing those tools of being able
to focus in school are not developing
which can lead to them falling behind
academically as they progress in their
academic careers
I believe if you take away the
requirement to fill out this paperwork
it will drop the language barrier which
many families face not being able to
speak English even if they could get to
Concord High by bus to meet with an ell
teacher who's going to say that the El
teacher will have time or is even there
to help them fill out the paperwork
it's crucial that every student has the
opportunity to eat food to be able to
learn in school and Thrive academically
food is fuel to your day I imagine going
to school every day being hungry imagine
doing your job right here right now
being hungry you wouldn't be able to
focus you wouldn't be able to listen
I mean I was in AP lip the other day and
I didn't eat enough and I felt like I
this past fall my school saved the
children club that held a food drive
around town in 14 local stores and we
raised 300 and collected 157 food items
we delivered that to Beaver Meadows
Elementary School which is a very high
need for food school they run a backpack
program they fill up every week and give
kids food when we arrived at that food
closet it was very alarming to see how
low it was and to know that these kids
will go home with like barely anything
in their backpacks to know that they
have to survive on potentially the one
meal they get at school per day that's
that's not okay that cannot be happening
it it just it's not
um so it was really great to be able to
give them that boost but I also want to
foreign
School the options for food at lunch is
Burgers pizza and like sometimes a salad
if kids can get there in time to get it
that's not nutritional the food in our
school needs to have nutritional value
so then you can actually feel like
you've had nutrition because if you
drink for instance like a sugary
something you're not going to feel like
you actually have energy compared to if
you had like a granola bar giving you
sustenance to be able to properly run
without your day
um I remember in ninth grade my best
friend kept asking me for granola bars
it's like why is he doing this and I was
like he's hungry and it hit me that he
comes from a lower income home and I was
like wow he might not have the same
access to food that I do and it was just
and of course I gave them the girl over
every day and anyone else who asked I
would it's just I honestly believe that
food is a human right and everyone
should have access to that so I urge you
to drop the language barrier of this
Medicaid require government so every kid
can have the opportunity to thrive in
school and be given an equal playing
field by having that taken away the
paperwork which is barring these kids
from being able to successfully thrive
in school thank you thank you very much
are there any questions from the
committee
thank you very much oh yes represent
Damon
I just want to know if you'd like me to
write a recommendation for your college
application
thank you but pepper you've been
submitted
thank you very much thanks
okay at this point in time uh we have
now the technical support which we can
utilize so Mark and uh Robert uh you're
both ones from HHS the others from doe
um so once you you know we we do have
some questions you know in follow-up to
what we did with representative umberger
uh with this program uh last year and so
um if you're if you want to sit together
foreign
there's this card right here and we've
had Mark before
I'll try to start why don't you go ahead
first Mark and then we're we're just you
know jab some of these questions at you
if you don't mind
um yeah I think there's three questions
there's probably more questions that you
kind of defer to technical assistance
um I think we got a history and a
background but um
uh the way the way the f r program works
by the way uh Mark manganol Department
of Education for the record the way f r
numbers work is you have the direct
certification program which is snap TANF
also Foster families and migration
um uh migrant migrant families um that's
a way to direct certify as yourself as
eligible for the f r program and so what
happens is that those are DHHS run
programs DHHS has that data DHS owns
that data but then there is a sharing of
data with the Department of Education
and most of the data lives and is owned
by DHHS but we give over sasid
information we give over information
that DHHS can use to match that data and
DHHS is able to take their data take our
data and say these are the students and
bring it back to us and say these are
the students that are part of these
programs TANF snap you name it so
they're able to match the data for us
and from there we're able to identify
which students are directly certified as
eligible to the fnr program program and
then we send that to the schools and
then the schools will have a direct cert
list and they can ensure that those
students are not either the way direct
cert and Kelly Rambo is in here she even
understood as the food and nutrition
program I believe every student who
directs certifies is labeled as free
meaning not free and reduced that means
they don't pay anything they don't pay a
reduced price they don't they get a they
get free meals
um
so the way that works is now everyone's
direct certified on a direct direct
certified list
um
um so that they can run their nutrition
program and know who to charge what and
and if the student receives a charge or
not the way this program's a lot we've
been studying this for for a while now
we've learned a lot we've answered a lot
of questions there's still some
questions that we we still have that the
department has but we've um to get to
representative leakis's question
um why since this is already State
Medicaid data why do we need to apply to
this program to get access to it and so
the Medicaid Program is regulated by CMS
and so CMS will not allow the Department
of Health and Human Services to just
hand over the data unless they're part
of this program so CMS they Grant a DHS
can talk more about Medicaid programs
but there's waivers and all these
processes but CMS will allow state
agencies to share this type of data if
they're in this program so the only way
we're going to get access to this data
the Department of Education from DHHS is
to be allowed to enter this program
authorized by USDA and then CMS will
allow DHHS to start share start the data
sharing process so that's that's one of
the reasons why um
you have to go through the USDA program
to access this
um I think I've answered a few questions
one uh representative cordelli talked
about the opt-outs questions we've been
discussing that I think for the past
year
um
I think last time we talked last time
this committee met and talked about this
back in the summer
there's kind of the ideas they're a
state opt-out or is there a local
opt-out the local opt-out would be this
uh the School receives that direct cert
list and they go the family could opt
out at the local level and say take me
off the list that would be a local
opt-out that seems
intuitive that that could be implemented
with some technical assistance from the
Department
um but that's a local opt-out it would
still revolve and still involve some
data going from DHHS
to the Department of Education to school
so it'd still be data sharing but there
would be opt out at the local level
um
we have to probably work with the
Department of Health and Human Services
to see if there's potential opt out at
the at the state application Level so
before the family even submits data to
the state they have now opt out at the
application Level
um and then that would be a policy
decision probably something we'd want to
talk with the legislature about about if
that off type opt out is something the
legislature is interested in
um this this we'd all have a set policy
on this but those are the questions
we've been discussing for the past year
as far as privacy and opt out what paths
what options would the program have
there's some unanswered questions there
as far as what can we reasonably
Implement I think the local opt-out
would be the we know we can Implement
that that that sounds pretty um feasible
I don't know if we can implement the
state level opt-out or state application
opt out
uh I think that answered a few of the
questions we had I don't know if we
um oh the the difference between the
Medicaid out of DHS could talk about it
the Medicaid application the fnr
application the Medicaid application I I
believe is a really uh difficult process
I don't know it's um I think it's a lot
of I think they might do do they do a
five-year look back on so the up on our
program I don't believe is doing a
five-year look back on your assets
um it's just for your income um the
Medicaid process is
um yes there's more work involved in
that process so there are two different
applications
uh good afternoon for the record Robert
Berry general counsel to the division of
Medicaid
um honestly a lot of people provided
everything I was going to say
um as um you know the chair indicated
earlier um this is going to be going
forward to a work session the department
uh was here really to offer its um
assistance with that work session I'm
working with Department of Education
this committee and stakeholders to come
up with a a piece of legislation that
everybody could be happy with
so if if we go ahead with a program like
this
will we end up with more
more student students for example at the
high school right now we're we see a
drop off with students participating in
the free and reduce program at the high
school and that's nothing new that's
been on for a long time uh will we see
this increase as a result of getting
involved with Medicaid in this and
that's my primary goal here is to ensure
that we have those high school students
which were not
uh affording that while we're affording
them the opportunity a lot of times
applications don't come in for the grade
school kids saw left on the school bus
or it's in the backpack or never even
gets into the backpack at school still
on their desk or wherever it might be
but with the high school kids there's
few of them returned and how do we get
then some structure in which we can we
know we have X number at the high school
that are are are not uh receiving this
benefit and we're not receiving the
benefit as a state for eligibility as as
poverty so that then it then it bounces
in everything we do our in our financial
formulas and the Career Technical
education with Carl Perkins all that we
our poverty rate will go up that's what
my goal is to just get more two things
get the kids all eating
and then secondly to try to get the
federal dollars which we're leaving on
the table
so can you speak that a little bit uh
Mark so I don't have a Medicaid um I did
get from director Lipman
um from DHHS I did get uh some Medicaid
data yeah
um
the Medicaid data is a little on the
pandemic just like a lot of data sets
the pandemic have influenced that data
set um currently and I don't know where
we're at currently with that but I know
that during the pandemic
uh people were not being disenrolled
from Medicaid in order because of the
public health emergency they were being
stayed on Medicaid even though they
would have been routinely up for real
re-enrollment or re-eligibility so that
I know that's phasing out eventually
um but a lot of the data set we have is
is inflated in the sense that no one was
been kicked off the rolls so we know
those data sets are high during the
pandemic
um the latest data set I got from DHHS
uh was as of July 1 2019 it said there
was 52 000 students ages 5 to 18. on
Medicaid and DHHS has narrowed in their
ability to get us the income numbers we
are looking for for our fnr program when
they originally gave it to us it was um
196 of the federal property guidelines
now it's up to 185 percent now it's
exactly at 185. so a better they've uh
DHHS has better fine-tuned they're
querying into their data and so
for July 2019 it's 52 000 kids for July
122. it's 56 000 kids uh 5 to 18 on
Medicaid
um uh that's a One Moment In Time
snapshot
so that is more than currently what we
have right now we're estimating for this
school year is 38 000 kids so are you
talking uh free and free and reduced the
38 000 38 000 yeah it's a significant
increase so yes and so I've done a
little bit of uh working with that data
um and running it through the formula
and uh so I have two different data sets
from DHHS I have one that has in
pandemic inflated numbers and I have one
number that's data set that's older but
not influenced by the pandemic so I came
up with a high and low estimate I'm
gonna work with Mickey landrigan with
the LBA to
um uh come with a number this is really
hard to estimate but just playing with
that data and kind of come up with a
ballpark number
um if we took that 2019 number and we
try to take our current enrollment
Decline and apply it to that number
um
ah and apply the same student
demographic enrollment client Trends to
it it gets us to around 47 000 students
so it's about 9 000 students more than
we're currently having so that's about a
9 000 student account jump in our f r
numbers
if I take that high number and just
leave it as is 56 000 and say that's a
high number so that'd be like a high
estimate
um that's a substantially more than the
38 000 we're carrying currently in the
formula and if I run both those numbers
and the impact on adequacy
um it would run through our formula I
have about either 22 million dollar
estimate or a 42 million dollar estimate
um this would impact fiscal year 26 so
we'd have a lot of time to
know what's coming
um if we and if this bill were to pass
um but that's currently where I'm at
that's a very ballpark figure it's very
difficult to estimate fiscal year 26. we
normally don't do that but if this
program were to pass we're talking about
you know dozens of millions of dollars
in the adequacy formula as far as
Federal money left on the table I think
we talked about this last summer the way
Federal money is received by the state
by the federal government to the state
by the federal government is usually
using census data but the way we
allocate out to our districts and our
communities is done using fnr data so
it's not going to increase
I believe I think last time we talked
about this I don't think it's going to
increase our Perkins allocation I don't
think it's going to increase our Title
One allocation
um but it would increase
um the number of students eligible
eligible for the program and every time
that student
um accesses that program
um instead of paying local sales revenue
about lunch money to the district the
federal government would pay for it so
there would be more Federal money for
schools because there would be less
lunch money so that's where we would put
more Federal money into our schools
um it would you know whether the
students pay for their lunch some of
them might run debts and however that
may work but that's that's what the
fundraal money would come into play
whether you're having worked at LBA and
knowing Mickey are are you going to be
able to get some of these spreadsheets
developed for us that you know show some
of this information you have right now
just projecting possibly this is my what
it might net Us in terms of funding
through the form education formula I can
give you a town by town
I I'd love just to see it by the state
or even if you have by Time by Town
that'd be even in regret you I think I'm
trying to at this moment in time
um
have Mickey I I I you know if you're if
we're gonna do a work session on this I
can give you a town by Town um I want
Mickey to put eyes on it I prefer but um
if you want to tell my town I have the
data so okay fine if you could be
working on that we're going to have some
kind of a session on that in about a
week or so okay
so it'd be good to have that so we can
have that in the discussion further
questions from the committee
representative cordelli uh thank you uh
maybe this is for you Mr chairman but uh
maybe my question would um a request
would be better held off into the work
session I'd like to talk about the data
matching process would maybe the work
okay why don't you hang on to that one
then so uh representative Woodcock thank
you chairman good afternoon gentlemen um
just some clarification if I may Mark
when you're talking about the direct
certification that Kelly had been
talking about you mentioned that it
brought everyone to free uh meals does
that negate the the reduced meal
um so our current programs bring
everyone to free our understanding and
and we've we've done we've talked to
we've had some meetings with USDA we
actually had a conversation uh Jen was
involved in it have a conversation with
Massachusetts our understanding is the
way the Medicaid Program is that
actually parses out free and reduced so
direct certification usually lumps
everyone into free the Medicaid direct
sir program as authorized by USDA allows
for granularity and parsing out free and
reduced
thank you
um on the non-uh Medicaid application uh
not the snap many of the processes is
there still going to be a option for
parents of youngsters that don't
currently on Medicaid and are
participating in any
uh you know my kids can I can I'm not
participating anything can I can I fill
out paperwork for my daughter and son
so I think if this were to be Bill were
to become law and we were to access the
program be approved for the program I
think the default policy by the
department would probably be to still
allow applications well meaning we're
not letting the applications go away
um
Massachusetts I believe last time we
talked to them
they've done direct cert right and they
they feel that I think they must feel
that they've done it to just an extent
that they've gotten rid of applications
okay
um so that would be probably a
legislative policy decision as far as do
you actually want to get rid of the
applications I mean only rely on Direct
certification but I think probably the
department would still allow the option
for applications you could have someone
who's in poverty but has private
insurance
um okay maybe so first let me have just
one more sure thank you
um the last one hopefully uh there's
been uh the eligibility you're talking
about the 130 and 187 that eligibility
is state number right that's a state
eligibility number I think it's a
federal guideline 135 185 so 185 185 187
the 130 and the 185 or the 187 that
number that's that's a federal guideline
yes okay is it regulated by the state at
all in this in the in the uh the school
of state board has the right to you
regulate that is that correct uh
so that's a good question for Kelly
um the state apparently has some
Authority in a sense we just moved uh we
just changed snap eligibility uh I think
I think probably the application I'm
just speculating here the application I
think is really highly governed by the
federal government but our feed-in
programs like snap we did change that to
200 percent right and that's going to
trigger increased direct certs okay um
so I I think the application might be
fully governed by the federal federal
regulations we might be stuck to that
but um that that's my guess may I just
fall sure where I'm going with that
thank you is we have a bill that's
coming forward that's looking at
um based on the from the summer meals
program no site based on the assumption
that the under the rules we saw the
State Board of Education has the right
although they haven't they have the
right to increase the eligibility so
bill that was coming forward was looking
at increasing the eligibility for free
agent's launch up to 300 percent
okay of the federal guidelines so my
question is
um here you talk now how it's regulated
with that with the direct certification
under the Medicaid process uh
just negate that or it was just a waste
or it it just won't fly
I don't know and now I think my my
assumption that this program's highly
federally regulated because the federal
money it's a lot of federal money it's
more mostly federally funded the f r
program
um I could be totally wrong there could
be some some policy quirks there that I
don't know
um so I can't answer that question
that's um maybe the DHS I don't know I
don't have an opinion on that was what I
was going to ask you for is what's the
uh the build number on that so I can
I probably responsively having a lapse
over here
anyhow we will get you that okay okay
but the the bill that has um the
dialogue from the summer talked about oh
thank you
uh so that that was the question and
what we don't want to do I mean our our
goal uh like representative Lads goal of
this goal is increase the participation
rate particularly those that
um can't do fully have not been eligible
um but in the Mystic guidelines we're
lowering the costs and the increases of
everything today we're hoping to expand
those that are eligible people from
Middle have made it before at the 180.
that was the intent of the bill but what
we don't want to do uh I'm speaking
myself assuming collectively for the
meal committee what we don't want to do
is is uh follow it up so to screw up the
whole process if you know what I mean
yep yeah I'll take a look at that yeah
education on that thank you thank you
representative I appreciate that thank
you we have uh you talk about
Massachusetts what about Maine Rhode
Island you know Vermont the ones other
New England states here are they we
heard I think some meant 30 states are
in this program
pardon me
39 Okay so
yeah there must be some other New
England states are in it as well
yeah we've only chatted with
Massachusetts about a year ago okay
further questions from the committee
yes represent Damon
thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question does
either one of you have even if it's you
know a generalized idea
how many
students there may be who
don't have Medicaid
even though they don't qualify or they
simply haven't applied
um may or may not have some other health
insurance maybe through a parent's
employer
but would qualify for free and reduced
lunch
in other words what's the gap
so I was actually thinking about that
question I'm not sure if the department
would be able to capture that because
we're not going to have any data on any
individual who's not
um snap or TANF or Medicaid so I was
thinking about that question though and
I will ask if we do have an ability to
capture that somehow I would doubt it
given that that we probably don't have
numbers on that
I appreciate the effort
Medicaid you said we had about roughly
56 38 47 000 kids possibly uh what are
we doing what's the adult population if
I had the adults on top of these kids in
grades 5 through 18. ages 5 to 18. so I
was looking at the numbers this morning
total Medicaid at the moment is around
250 000. now that is
um inflated because of the public health
emergency and the maintenance of effort
requirements
um come April 1st we will start to be
able to
um
um I don't know what the proper word for
it is but look at eligibility and assess
properly thank you
are there any other other questions
right in the yes represent
representative leckis
thank you thank you for taking my
question you had referred to in
answering my earlier question
um
is that federally governed or state
governed and is that something we could
change at the state level so that there
could be sharing from State Medicaid you
know between that and the doe as far as
doing our own direct certification like
we do with TANF and WIC and those other
things
that would have to be something we have
to really look at when we go through a
data sharing process at the department
we we look at all the available
authorities we go from the federal
government to the extent it's a federal
um federally funded or you know
federally involved program we look at
the state Authority and we look at
things like that so it's it's a rather
involved and
um
you know a long process in terms of when
we decide how we share data and how
we're going to do it so that's something
we could certainly take a look at
um you know our understanding is that
Medicaid data really has to be protected
absent some sort of federal Authority
but we can we can certainly take a look
thank you very much we're going to have
one more question represent Damon that's
the last one
thank you it's short
so I just wanted to hopefully verify I
believe the federal Omnibus act that was
passed at the end of 22
um
will continue Medicaid certification for
children that they'll have continuous
enrollment are you familiar with that I
am familiar with that I'm trying to
remember the provision though I it
sounds familiar to me I think that
um begins
I want to say next January yes I think
so too so the reason I brought it up was
just that that would be relevant to what
happens with this that kids wouldn't
fall off Medicaid and therefore they
wouldn't fall off yes they continuously
this bill went through thank you
and no more questions uh for the
Department for HHS we have a work
session scheduled for February 1st at 9
yes I I've written that down and I have
these questions and I'll be working on
getting some answers for everybody for
that day and and if Kelly could also you
know be around Mark yep thank you we'll
talk about data sharing as well thank
you good
so thank you very much everybody I don't
have any other pink cards on this bill
so I'm going to close the hearing on 601
and take about five minutes to stretch
and then we have one smaller bill here
which we have representing lunos taking
okay so I noticed you asked him to be on
the social studies thing this is a young
I just asked him I want to get in
contact with him and I hear something
like that yeah
shake Advantage she's really okay
okay
[Music]
our last bill in front of us here so
we're going to go ahead
HP 435 relative to relief Aid
calculation and determining grants for
adequate education representative luno
welcome thank you very much Mr chair
it's been uh been wonderful to be with
uh with everybody in House Education
this afternoon
um uh for the record uh Dave luno
Merrimack County District 9 uh the
people of Bowen Hopkinton and all over
the great Granite State
um uh here to introduce House Bill 435
this came to me at the request of the
department and um and we've got Mark
mancinella who's going to be be here
from the Department to uh to speak in
just a minute to uh back to the enhanced
free and reduced price lunch grants that
um uh that came in as part of the the
state budget uh I believe came in as
part of the state budget it updates the
the grant levels based on based on where
where those level
uh should be at this point it eliminates
the proration clause in the um in the
statute and it adds a biennial cost
adjustment uh so that we can basically
get this set and um and let this uh
continue to run so with that that
concludes my quick introduction remarks
and I just soon handed over to to the
department for uh technical
thank you any questions uh
representative luno
great thank you all very much thank you
yeah
welcome
uh for the record marketing hello
Department of Education School Finance
um the reason why what this bill is
doing two things it's adjusting the
rates and then it's getting rid of the
um set in stone proration number so the
way the relief aid grant works is we
calculate your Aid amount based on your
fnr percentage for each community and if
we come up with that number
um but we don't use that number well we
use that number what we do is we prorate
up or down to 17.5 million so if we do
the calculation and Statewide it turns
out to be 15 million we are going to Pro
jump every Community up well I should do
some easier math I'm not gonna we'll
jump it up to uh we'll jump it up by
whatever percentage the increase is
necessary to bring it up to 17.5 million
if we calculate if we do the math do it
on the formula and it turns out to be 20
million we'll throw it everyone down to
whatever percentage so that the
Statewide total is 17.5 million and so
what's good about that is it creates a
budget control creates a budget control
for Budget writers that they know
exactly how much they're going to spend
is 17.5 million but as we become more
comfortable with the fnr date fnr data
or this calculation and what this will
do
um we would like to ideally have these
formulas stand alone and float and not
be anchored to a proration number
um and the reason why that works is
because
um it really we do have 30 cooperatives
all cooperatives have a Cooperative
apportionment and when we are doing
Cooperative apportionments we account
for every single well not every single
penny we don't do it to the penny we do
everything can we count to every single
dollar of adequacy funding to go to each
Community each Town that's in a
um in a Cooperative apportionment and so
when we change the school funding
formula
with relief aid meaning
um the fnr data manipul changes for one
Community by one kid it changes it for
all 233 towns if all 233 towns were
eligible for this so that means there's
about a dollar change for all of these
towns and it creates more administrative
work because now we have to account for
all those dollar changes on every
Cooperative apportionment so it's just a
lot more keying
um because now every single Community
has a change in their adequacy
um
um relative to what we use to set the
tax rate and what they were actually
paid and it comes into the Cooperative
apportional process so it's really
behind the scenes
um uh inside baseball but when me and my
team have to do Cooperative
apportionments it becomes very sort of
tedious tracking every single dollar
change
um because in the proration is causing
that dollar change
um so if we let the formula float
um we we bring it to a 17.5 million
dollar number
um
using uh just changing the rates not
using a proration factor
um it's going to be administratively
okay any questions from the committee
um does this affect overall the budget
of the state or does it just does it
even out
so when I first did this calculation and
handed this to representative luno it
did not now looking at the latest data
it actually is going to be I did the
latest I'd use these numbers that I have
figured in here
um it's 500 000 less so if you were to
send this bill to finance we could take
the latest data and try to bring this
closer to completely state budget
neutral right now it's um a 500 000
savings
um in the state budget but I think as
this if this bill made it's a second
committee and we worked uh with binance
we would try to bring it right to budget
neutral thank you
further questions
yes represent Damon
thank you Mr chair
well let me preface this by saying I am
not a good numbers person
so if right now it's 500 000 less to the
state am I correct in thinking that
that's 500 000 less to the districts
correct
and how is it that you would make it be
neutral
um I would I would just play with the
numbers a little bit so that that's 672
for
um I I followed a I think I followed a
four times uh uh so like originally it
was 150 to 600 so it's the low end Grant
it was 150 and the high end Grant was
600. so I would just add another dollar
to that low end so if I added that to
169 and then I five times it by four
um to the top end that would be
176. so I would play with those numbers
to make the total calculation come up to
17.5 million
but it's Tinker out of Tinker with the
numbers a tad bit
follow up yes
so then in subsequent years the number
is changing correct based on F and our
data
um so it wouldn't be set in stone to
17.5 million so if say we did direct to
cert Medicaid
um
in subsequent years the f r numbers
might be better than they are currently
um so that would make this formula more
expensive
um if the snap program is successful in
getting new applicants to direct certify
the fnr numbers would go up
um so as F and our data moves so would
this number move the only other
adjustment we're making here is we are
doing CPI adjustments
CPI adjustments to the uh budget numbers
there to the factor numbers so we're
trying to make it flow with inflation
um based on regular adequacy but we're
trying to not live within that 17.5 set
in stone number and have the formula
flow but there is challenges with having
a formula float
thank you are there further questions
from the committee
I thought we were already doing a CPI
adjustment every biennium
um not to the only to base and
differentiate okay okay extraordinary
needs Grand stabilization none of those
are getting CPI guys okay
further questions
not seeing any I think we're done thank
you
so and that does conclude this bill
it's closed and
yes just a quick question I don't know
if you know this off the top of your
head but I have all the lsrs that have
been submitted to education been
assigned a house bill number
yeah yes they have been and you know
what that count is out of curiosity well
I think it's 91. I I had one that I
could not find it it wasn't it was on
our list but when I went to the website
it was never there
and we found out there was a technical
problem over at the with the ti Guys
across the street so we did have that
one added on today but uh we're also
we've also vacated a couple of them so I
think that we're hovering right around
91 that's not counting any Senate bills
was it 139 last year yeah you got to
remember last year we had 139 bills
between the house and the Senate between
the house and the Senate yeah
no
and wait until we get some of these
I think so
I think we talked about that earlier
today